hello hello everybody hello hello welcome to oh yeah good
morning to you guys it's like 8 p.m for me good night to you
yeah welcome to the girl squad we are the top 500 girl squad
hero is top 500 in our hearts yeah yeah yeah yeah she's At
least top 500 in my heart Well at least in your heart Yeah
yeah most important right Yeah that's most important Exactly
Exactly Yeah and ditto's heart too Yeah and ditto's heart
You're like rank 500 But in my heart You're like Top 10 Wow
Wow what a difference in treatment Yeah ditto That's so
messed up Why is she only 500 I didn't say that you didn't
say no you didn't argue you accept you let me say it it's
too late to say it's too late it's too late to defend
yourself oh that means i was right no you're not you're not
it's never friendship is never too late she's my top um top
tea Wait, what am I?
You don't even have a thousand friends.
That's so sad.
You don't even have a thousand friends!
I can't deny that.
I don't have 1 000 friends.
Yeah, why am I...
Okay, there's one number of...
I don't even have 10.
You don't even have 10, but on top of 1,000?
I'm really...
That's so fucked up.
Is it because I played power with her recently?
I was supposed to be there, but it was...
I fell asleep.
I fell...
That's not fair.
I fell asleep.
It was my idea, too.
I had the idea.
idea to play do it yeah i was like yeah i was like oh where
did she keep coming no igl you're the highest rank why
you're the highest rank we are okay you're you're silver
what you're silver one i'm silver three it's not it's not
that different from zero t it's two tiers it was same oh my
god okay guys how's the volume i don't know if sound guys
alive so my mom My other mod, it's your job to balance now.
My other mod has to balance.
That's my pret trail.
It's the legacy.
Oh my gosh.
Please carry me.
It's the legacy trail.
Carry me.
No, Silver One has to...
You guys are pulled.
You can be...
Silver One has to carry.
I have one RP right now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, and we have a silver.
one player she's so good at this game oh my god oh my god
silver one ditto how how did you get to silver one i i don't
feel like i'm playing a base you don't feel like you're
playing what what are oh my god maybe i i play too much czz
you play czz oh my god czz oh no she can't aim anymore she
can't aim it's okay i okay you're washed honestly you too i
feel weird two games two games two games we all are we're
washed guys guys we used to be like i need two most girls
guys we used to be the apex girls in our country what
happened what happened to us oh wait oh my god my chat's not
okay my chat's not showing okay you have auto sprint on i do
too yeah yeah wait what you guys have auto sprint on yeah
i'm lazy yeah i'm lazy yeah i'm lazy i'm lazy You don't!
You're actually- It's the first time I've heard- It's the
auto sprint on!
I've been auto sprinting since season two.
Wow.
What a pearl.
I know.
I'm just lazy.
There's no reason to like walk.
In rank, you don't walk.
You don't walk in rank.
You only walk?
You don't walk?
I walk.
Okay, because like, you know- Yeah, because you're always
W-keying, you know?
You're always W-keying.
If you're, it's a competitive, yeah, and competitive, you
have to walk because you're sneaking up on people.
Look, I walk right now.
No, no, no, no.
In competitive team, I don't walk.
You don't walk, that's why we die.
Okay, I'm gonna walk the entire time.
That's not your fault.
Yeah.
All right, next week, isn't it?
Don't you have a tournament next week?
No, you guys, you guys die before I die.
Oh, okay, you bet.
So that's not my fault.
All right, here, you heard that?
She said we die before her.
You hear that?
I'm lifeline.
That means somebody's not getting res.
Oh my god.
Yeah, please, please.
Yeah, please what?
He's gonna die.
What do you mean, I never die?
I'm lifeline.
We will see.
We're gonna die for it.
You're literally pathfinder.
I like how we did not...
Oh, wait.
What can you scan?
This is a people scanner, right?
Yeah.
yeah yeah nothing is a rig scanner okay okay guys we're so
washed i don't even remember i forgot how to open the map oh
you played too much zzz we can't wait we can't counter it i
feel like pathfinder is so slow why why why why he moves so
slow you picked pathfinder what do you mean i feel like i
feel like um he moves really slow are you sure you are you
sure you have auto run on are you are you are you on are you
on past 60 frames are you are you look at me look at me is
he is is he you're walking you're walking you're walking
you're walking oh wait okay okay i missed i missed you okay
okay okay
What happened to you?
Wait, there's actually somebody here?
Oh no, guys, guys.
I need to raise up here.
Oh, okay.
I can.
Oh, a sound guy.
Raise up here.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
Okay.
I knew I'd be closer.
I can't...
How could you not tell you were walking?
How did you not see that?
Wait.
I'm gonna...
Grab a package.
They're still...
Oh, did I see you?
Yeah.
Ditto weapons!
Ditto where?
Ditto, I need his place.
He's hiding.
She's hiding.
Okay.
Guys, guys.
Give me a sec.
I'm looting.
Okay.
He's hiding.
Where are you?
Here, here.
He's down here.
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Oh, wait.
Let me revive her.
We're still resting.
Yeah.
We can't.
That's me.
Yeah.
I'm back!
Okay.
You got instant res.
Remember, you're crypto.
Wait, they're like pushing me.
It's okay.
Just raise her.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
We'll use her as bait and then she can die again.
Oh.
Okay.
Doki can do one with two.
I can one with three.
They're running away.
I can do one.
No!
They're running away.
They ran away after killing me.
They caused me.
They caused me and they ran away.
There's another team.
Oh, that's why.
Okay, it's okay.
We can go through it.
I'm going left side.
I will get my two ex-cop and I will follow you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ditto, what happened?
You died first!
Ditto!
No, no, don't!
Okay, they were hiding!
He was hiding!
I don't know.
I didn't see it.
Did you see a hero?
Was he hiding?
Well, I was wondering.
I think those are excuses.
I think...
It's okay.
He was hiding.
It's because she was walking.
Yeah, yeah.
she was walking yeah yeah yeah honestly you're right you're
right it's okay it's okay it's okay to die first you know we
know every pred player makes mistakes you know no no no oh
you don't make mistakes yeah i don't because i'm the base
apis player oh it depends on your igl yeah all right igl
what do you want to do what should we do igl Okay, we go, we
go landslide.
Okay, okay.
We go landslide.
I'm behind you.
Okay, looky, looky.
Give me battery.
Give you battery.
Okay, here.
Here.
Okay, nice.
Even Aki don't have a battery, by the way.
I had two.
You could have, you should have asked.
He's like, yeah.
He's looking for a heel.
Wait, how did Dino know I had battery?
I have two.
I don't know.
I just, I just asked you.
Oh my gosh, she has...
She has inventory walls.
Oh my gosh, she's cheating.
She has walls You can only look at you I brought up the game
volume a little bit sound guy Oh, follow me, follow me We're
following, we're following So it's faster Wait, they're
actually there We go, we go here, we go here, we go here,
we're going There's a table in front of me It's okay, I will
cover you guys Guys, guys, I'm fucking Wait, I broke his
armor?
Yeah, yeah, I broke one armor.
I broke one armor too.
That one's low?
Oh, okay.
Almost okay.
All right.
That guy?
There's two teams.
Two teams.
I'm backing to you.
Last one?
Wait, I'll EMP them.
What?
Yeah, oh my god.
They're all split up.
We're fine.
Okay, we gotta go to zone.
We gotta go.
I believe me.
We gotta go to zone, guys.
Yeah.
Can you move here?
Wait, I shocked all them, by the way.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Armor charge.
They have to come to us.
They're all here.
They're all there.
Yeah, they have to come to us.
Why?
I think they don't want to fight.
Yeah, they don't want to fight.
Wait, wait.
I don't know.
Not the team.
Yeah, okay, okay, okay, okay.
That's not the team.
They're coming.
Zip, Zip.
Shoot him.
Don't get him.
He's so long.
I got him.
We're team.
He's cracked.
Oh.
yo hey he's so low let me go there go there go there i got
him i got him nice and here um i'm late yeah go to get him
i'm also good i'm so good wait wait he helped you though
He's what he's what he's what he's going on.
I'm so good.
Wait, he's got his gole.
I need his own here.
You're so good guys.
I need like energy.
Oh, over here in front of me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, he has the zip line buff.
Oh my god.
Another team.
Oh my god, I got him.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's another team?
I knocked him.
Okay, I'm coming.
Oh, here.
This is slow.
Don't get, come here, don't, don't go inside the lane.
Come with us, come with us.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
Oh my god, last one, last one.
I'm here, guys.
Yay.
There's so many people, why?
Is there still people?
Why?
Why did everybody come to us?
I don't know.
It went from zero players to like a hundred.
This is everybody.
Yeah, everybody came to us.
Nice, okay.
not ready for this i i don't have a ammo yeah i had i ran
out of ammo during this fight i can't hear energy ammo in
this boss okay oh i need energy yeah oh my god it was like
200 people just showed up i have heal drone for us here okay
okay i i'll put this down oh nice it's a okay we go there we
go there okay uh oh wait where did you guys go oh there you
guys are oh there's one team oh yeah oh my god it didn't
activate it one team where oh behind us behind us behind us
behind us okay we killed him okay okay okay yeah yeah yeah
we killed him okay okay okay yeah we killed one guy oh my
god oh my god there's a guy right here left right here left
okay there's a guy right here left okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
imp them okay just give me a second okay okay there's a guy
to our left here too i'm getting across I'm gonna cross here
Okay, they have to come to us They have to come to us Hugh,
fuse, almost keg Looking, I'm looking What?
What are you looking?
Nice one, nice one, nice one Okay, they didn't have a ton
They have to come to us They're alting, they're alting They
have to go this way Here, here, I'm watching I'm watching,
I'm watching too No, no, they went there, they went there
They should cross here, they should cross here
Oh nice nice I'm pushing I'm pushing up wait I'm lifeline
friend lining I'm lifeline friend lining oh shit what the
fuck dead where's the last guy on me all dead all dead all
nice nice nice we're so good at this game guys oh my god we
should be like a team like an actual team guys oh my god we
good we good we're so good against these silver players i i
i feel bad for them i don't they should okay i know i
thought you wouldn't they should stay in this area come here
come here let's go yeah yeah yeah okay we go third third
party okay one one team that one team Yeah.
That's- that's- that's- I'll join here.
Alright.
I'm here.
There's four teams.
Four teams.
Okay.
I see him.
In front of me.
They're fighting.
Here, here.
Here.
In front of me.
I'm gonna bat.
I'm batting.
Oh, yeah.
He's one.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Who's shooting me?
Left side here.
Left side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
oh careful i can't i can't see anything right now oh i'm
pushing up with you like god is that your all oh no that's
your dash i'll scan them i'll scan oh my god they have they
have um golden they have golden knock oh my god how dare
they i want that yeah what do you mean i should have oh we
know i already had aEP oh well i got everyone on hold on i'm
on me i'm me i'm me
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I have to bet.
I have to bet.
Yeah, yeah, they're getting shot at.
Oh, wait.
120, 120.
I'm looking, I'm crossing, I'm getting across, Bree.
Okay.
Got him, I got him.
Left side?
On the team, okay.
Here, I'm looking here.
You have the left side of the team.
Okay.
Nice nade.
Not my, not my, okay, I'm not bang alert by the way, but...
Wait, someone see?
Ooh!
They did it, they did it, they did it, they did it.
Okay, I'm batting him.
Come here, come here!
He don't help you, I'm your bat, I'm your bat.
Okay.
I'm getting rid of the Watson Gen.
Jesus Christ, this Watson Gen is so...
I will push this guy.
Okay, I'm getting my package.
Here, here, here, here, yeah, here, here, here, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Right there.
Marage one, Marage one, Marage one!
Oh my god, which one is it though?
Nice, nice, nice, full dead, full dead.
left wow okay oh my god i don't have ammo over there over
there over there oh i see i see them oh there oh there's a
gold rest gold right there's a last team last team only one
we're so last oh my god i don't have i don't have heavy ammo
yeah go look look look there's so many bodies they're here
they're here they're here okay okay okay okay i see one guy
one guy it's one guy oh it's two guys it's two guys two two
two yeah oh don't give fake news Yeah, that's right.
What you gonna do, huh?
You can't do anything about it.
Okay.
Wait, I'm pushing.
I'm pushing.
Yes!
I got you!
No, no, no, no!
They're so low!
They're all low!
I hit them even though I was distracted.
They're so low, you can't lose this.
They're bad.
Yeah, that's good.
Guys, I don't know.
I think we're gamers.
guys i think that was our first round yeah that was our
first game guys i i you know i helped you guys with the last
team you're just you're baiting it's okay yeah i was the
meat yeah i was the meat shield that was the meat shield
look at us oh my god we got 20 cat kills together that's
crazy oh Just re-queue here.
Yeah, we don't have to go back.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
So in my chat was like, wow, you guys can get, you guys
might be able to get gold.
Really?
Do you think we're good enough for gold?
Oh, my God.
I've never been gold before.
My God.
But dude, you're a friend.
No, no, no, I'm not.
I'm silver two.
I'm silver three.
I don't know what you're talking about.
No.
I'm just...
Once you're a friend, a race friend.
No, that's not...
That's not true.
Ditto, you literally started...
You didn't know what was walk and run.
You were a more recent friend than me.
Yeah.
Why is Pathfinder so heavy?
You were walking for like 30% of that game.
We got out of...
We got out of Climatizer and you were still walking.
Oh my god.
I missed the same thing.
Yeah and you were prayed.
Ditto.
What happened?
No.
I I play um too much other game But I play other games Yeah,
I play other games too I knew I was running No, I haven't
been playing a baseball Why Almost one month I'm gonna, okay
I'm gonna Really?
I don't believe that I don't believe that I'm gonna look at
her VODs right now Only one week One week I think one week
Only one week One week one or two one or two four days what
do you mean yes no I pay only one game I pay one game and my
internet date five days ago you still streamed Apex five
days that was only one game four days and five days oh so
that's two games and two days yeah two games day yeah so you
play one game a day one game a day wow and yeah you still
don't know if you're running or walking no did uh what
happened did oh what happened to you but my aim is still
good that's that's why oh i have a this is so nice look
there's a wingy your aim is still good did go pick up the
wingman oh okay okay wait really yeah she said her aim is so
great so she should pick up the wingman yeah okay i i will
use wingman all right did it do you think do you think
dido's gonna do you think she's gonna hit her shots well i
believe i believe you know what i'll
Okay, if you don't get- Dino, if you get most damage, most
kills, I'll give you five subs.
Wow!
Really?
Yeah, but only wingman.
You have- Don't you- Only wingman?
Yeah, only wingman.
You can- Okay, only wingman.
Your inventory has to be two wingmans.
Okay, two wingmans.
Okay, find me another wingman.
Yeah, yeah.
If Hero and I- If Hero and I, either of us, does more kills
and damage than you, you have to get- You have to give us-
five you don't you don't have you don't have to help um
dorky just let her die first
you have to kill people too you have to shoot people as well
i'll scan them don't worry i'll be helping i'll have zero
damage but you know i'm just scanning them all right let's
we need to find it there's actually one squad here by the
way we need to find one more wingman for not yet not yet we
need to find one more wingman for for i scanned them what oh
where where did you scan them i i don't find yeah wait they
actually find a wingman yeah where's wingman where's another
wingman we need another wingman for a ditto wingman guys we
can't fight yet until ditto has two wingmans we can't you
know Wingman is too weak.
It has only six bullets.
Yeah, but then if you have two wingmans, then you'll have 12
bullets.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Just remember, two wingmans, 12 bullets.
It's okay.
I can kill them with two bullets.
Yeah.
I believe in you.
Yeah, you said your aim is so good today, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
You used to be the wingman queen.
Remember?
Okay, okay.
nickname yeah when we first collapsed her entire thing was
about wingman she was known for yeah she was known for yeah
don't remember i don't remember you don't remember yeah even
she doesn't remember yeah you used to be like people be like
oh my god ditto and wingman back then and you would always
play wingman yeah it was like three years ago you would
always play wingman did you misunderstand me with someone no
i'm pretty sure i am i can't remember when did they say that
what do you mean when back then when you first got pregnant
you would always hold on to the wingman oh my gosh she
doesn't remember oh my gosh she doesn't remember she's
getting old she's
You, no, no, you gaslighting me.
I can literally look at your channel.
Yeah.
I preached our clips.
I think I have been playing SMG and Assault Ivan.
I think she's gaslighting us.
No, you.
You're the one.
No, no, no.
You're gaslighting us.
Oh my God.
You used to pick up the wingman all.
the time your old age is getting to you you're getting old
ditto no she's she's gonna be grandma only 17.
only 17.
grandma ditto oh my god oh my god grandma if if if i were a
gamma you might be um older than gamma oh i'm older no no no
no no no no wait is this is that enemy is that enemy let me
let me check for you all right don't worry hira can check
for us so far it is an enemy yeah that's me that's me you're
fine another wing run ping me okay don't worry we will i
want a havoc oh my god did you have a hiding you're fighting
wait did loba loba's running yeah yeah oh my god the sea
maybe they're gonna be like uh wait i have zero damage i'm
gonna i'm gonna scan for you guys yeah no you yeah you need
help us at least get the evil harvest you know get the evil
harvest Wait, I can't get it with my drone.
You can't?
I thought you killed, no.
They have two parties, two parties.
Oh, you did damage.
You did damage.
No, say no.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
One.
Oh, 45, 45, 45, 1 on 45.
Okay, I can't do anything.
Blue armor, blue armor.
Yeah, they both have blue armor.
90, 90.
Are you making up numbers?
I don't think she's hitting them.
I think she's making it up.
Oh, there, oh, there, oh, there, oh, we have to back out.
Oh, whoa.
I think that...
Oh, there are so many people here.
There's too many.
We have to go around.
Why?
Why they focus us?
I know.
Why are they focusing us?
I'm backing out.
Oh, I think we should go there.
Yeah.
I'm here.
I hit.
I hit landslide.
Goodbye, guys.
Goodbye.
Dido, you stop making up that, like, when you hit shots,
stop pretending you hit them.
Yeah, I hit them.
I hit them Dero You don't have to pretend Dero I hit them I
hit them You can see my You're like I'm getting gaslit From
both of you It's like No I'm gonna leave Hiro Hiro did you
Hiro In your drone Did you hear Did you see No no Doki Doki
is a gaslighting queen No no no no no She always gaslighting
people That is not true I would never Gaslight people I'm
gonna grab this True people take and then steal your damage.
I'm gonna...
I have... Oh my god.
And then grab it.
Oh, wait there.
Oh!
Okay.
Let me know if you guys find...
If you guys find a sniper, let me know.
I need one more wingman.
I can fly... I can't find another wingman.
It's okay.
We'll find...
We'll find more wingmans for you.
Don't worry.
I'll find... Yeah.
I'll try to find one here.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe there is one.
Yeah, there has to be at least one, right?
Oh, I hear shots.
Okay.
I have one.
Oh, you found it?
You found it?
Yeah.
Really?
No, no.
Not yet.
Oh, no.
I just got the red armor.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so strong now.
Yeah.
Yeah, you don't have to shoot.
You don't have to shoot.
I can't believe you already did 2,000 damage.
Yeah, guys, I already did 2,000 damage, guys.
I did 4,000 damage for this red armor.
Wait, there's actually somebody.
Oh.
Wait, where is it?
I think we're done.
Wait, in front of us?
Wait, let me look.
There's two squads.
Two squads.
No, no, they're not.
Maybe they are on the left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
way okay you go first oh so i could die first is that it no
i'll cover you what are you talking you know why are you
talking i'm doing this i don't see them oh i see them oh i'm
flying to the air all right i'm gonna get to the high ground
here but you're joking i'm going here huh he goes right in
front of me wait we're Both not there, don't keep it.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why did you guys... What?
Who here is?
Leave me!
They're right here.
They're right here in front of me.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, yeah.
Let me EMP them for you.
Wait, I can't, I can't.
Kank, Kank, Kank, one, I can't Kank one.
Oh my god, Kank the other, I cracked the Bangalore?
They have two, they have two, they have two.
Okay.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I shocked them again.
They have to- Oh my god, Hiro's doing damage.
Hiro's doing damage right now.
I almost Kank one.
Okay, okay, I'm going behind.
I'm going behind.
Hiro, we need your help, Hiro!
You got this!
No, I don't!
No, I got no!
She's gonna do it!
Hiro, come here, Hiro!
Wait, calm down, Doki.
I have one, enough one!
Nice, nice, nice!
I'm batting, I'm batting!
Okay, I broke one.
Actually, I'm gonna thirst him then.
I'm getting his armor.
Yeah, he's tall!
Let's go!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Where?
With me, with me!
Whoa!
Wait, should he be broke?
I got one!
okay nice another one another one last guy look at the left
me left me here
what's the point of playing lifeline but um get it get it
get it get it get it i have cold breaths i have cold breaths
okay okay okay i give you a okay i'm gonna die first okay
Raise me!
Cover, cover, cover, cover!
I cracked, I cracked the lobo!
Oh!
Wait!
Oh shit!
He's low!
Okay, slow!
Guys, wait!
She's...
She's Tori!
Kill her!
Another team!
Another team is shooting me from 10 miles away by the way!
Oh my god.
Yes, I got the most damage.
Shoot you late.
I was going to.
I had to get army.
I had to refresh my army.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
I did resue.
Secretly just because we wanted the damage?
.
would just knife me and gain um only damage that's not true
that is not true i wait i know people if if i had to rage
quit did already oh my god no i got i got dc i got dc in
front of me did a rage quit she got dc she's like here oh
wait oh wait you want me i can shine she actually
you hear me didn't you hear me i said i got dc you got d
yeah dc yeah yeah yeah yeah disconnect i got yeah yeah
didn't disconnect i really got disconnected
what happened to your okay double or nothing we can double
it if you if you have more damage on wingman 10 subs 10 subs
okay wait I only had one wingman yeah so that's not that's
not I will find you I will find no you don't help me finding
my wingman I found you the first wingman what do you mean
Hero didn't find you the second wingman here here oh my god
oh my god Now you get everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you can't complain.
You can't complain anymore, Ditto.
Hey, double, double.
If you get more damage than Hero or I.
I will get more damage this time.
Yeah, okay.
I believe you.
Alright, where do we land Hiro?
Alright Ditto, where do we land?
Here Ditto.
Land somewhere where you can get a wingman.
Oh, okay.
Maybe here are teams.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, there's no teams here.
Yeah.
We can we can dirt them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, then I'll just go here.
Oh, I'll land here.
We're so slick.
I can't believe Ditto.
I can't believe Ditto rage quit.
Oh my gosh.
No, I said I got dainty.
She's so angry.
I got dainty.
Yeah, yeah.
DC.
I got this blank then.
It's M.
Yeah, we believe you.
We believe you, Ditto.
DC.
Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
It has.
to be dc it's dc
of course yeah yeah dc dc
okay next time we play next time we play with rpr okay i
will i will i will help up here no wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait you're
right you're You're right, you're right.
It is a DC.
I believe you.
I didn't believe you.
That was fun.
No, we have to fight our VR together.
I have not found a wingman yet.
It's okay.
There's wingman here.
Oh, okay, nice.
Oh, where?
Okay.
Are we good?
Got it.
Okay.
Oh, you're fine.
You're stunning.
We are?
Okay.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Which, I don't have wingmen.
Yeah, go grab your wingmen.
Okay.
There's three wingmen.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Go grab it.
Wait, why were you running to me, Dido?
Dido?
Dido was running to me.
She thought I was, you know.
I saw her, like, next to me.
I'm running to heal.
No, I saw you running to me.
I saw you at the bridge.
I'm so sad.
I watched it.
It was at the bridge.
I can't believe Ditto couldn't remember what hero looks
like.
Oh, that's so bad.
That's so bad.
You said I was your top three.
Yeah, you were top three.
Yeah, you were lying.
It's not lying.
Then why were you at the bridge?
I was farming.
I was farming what?
I was there.
Weeman.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, I'm ready.
Wait, I down one?
Oh, you down one?
That one?
Nice, nice.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you...
You zipponed them.
It's over?
Yeah.
Yeah, I...
Okay, I have one.
I have one wingman.
Wait, you're supposed to have two?
He must get so pissed though.
No, I got wingman and backpack.
Oh, okay.
So we need another wingman.
Only one is fine.
Okay, only one.
Only one is fine for now.
They're so angry.
Wait, how are you so angry?
Why are they angry?
Why did you make him angry?
Yeah, why did you make them angry?
So that Ditto can go and kill everybody.
Ditto, why- Why aren't you here yet?
Go, Ditto, the rest.
Yeah, the rest...
Yeah, now's your chance.
I'm just gonna lose.
Hey, Hey, here.
Oh my shit!
In front of me?
I broke him.
He's damaged.
I broke him, Ditto.
I'm batting.
I'm batting, I'm batting.
Alright.
Wait.
she's low this one's low wait on me this one's low can you
call me okay okay she's she's raising me she's raising me
okay all right okay wait what do you mean come back there
okay i told you i can do it i don't need you guys okay let
me finish him no no no I hope you get shot.
I hope you get shot.
Wait, she's here.
He's here.
He's right here.
Where?
Okay, he's gonna run.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys.
You follow me.
You kill him.
You need this more than us.
We're gonna loot.
Wait, did you hear that?
Wait, wait, is that a- Yeah, did you hear that?
Yeah, that's somebody.
Wait, he's here!
He's here!
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Only one!
No!
I said, get up!
Only one, only one, only one damage.
Ditto!
Ditto, why did you leave us?
Crap us, Ditto!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ditto kept us!
Dude, uh, crapped us and Reza's.
That was so, that was like, they just landed on us.
Yeah, we were like, wait a minute, isn't that?
Is that, is that like a landing?
Yeah, I was like, isn't that landing?
Did somebody like fall on us?
I'm a, I'm a Reza guy here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it's okay.
Even 1v3.
They're gonna loot.
Yeah, you can 1v3.
You want that 10 subs.
Can't believe it.
Ditto hates us, you know.
She left us to die.
No.
They're coming.
They're there.
Where are they?
They're on the hill.
On the hill?
I didn't see them.
Which one?
Which way?
Wait, wait, let me think.
Did you actually see them?
Yes, I did.
Actually.
Okay.
I see them.
Over here.
they're late hit one hit one oh the armor oh the vantage oh
there one guy yeah yeah the vantage is looking at me she's
looking at me oh I'm backing out I'm backing out I want
Ditto to be closer to them alright they're too far yeah they
have to come to us do you want to go loot yeah let's get
some loot yeah Wait, what?
Behind, behind is another team?
Wait, wait, oh, shit.
Okay, I'll go first.
All right.
Be careful, be careful.
Oh, it's okay.
This is okay.
This doesn't take, we don't take more damage here.
Yeah, we take less damage.
Oh my god.
Mirage, Mirage.
Wait, why are there so many people?
No, what do you mean?
Why is there?
It's okay.
He ran to them.
He ran to the team.
In front of me, in front of me, in front of me, in front of
me.
Oh, that's a lot.
That's a lot of people.
Is that Mirage?
On me, on me, on me.
That one?
I got the other?
Wait, they're all dead.
Oh my god!
There's more, there's more, there's more!
Okay.
Be careful, be careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's more.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I'm looting so much, okay.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck did they come from?
Ambulus got me.
There was like people there, but they like ran away.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
They like showed up.
They came out of nowhere.
But they lose to us.
Yeah, they're so bad.
Oh my god.
They're so bad.
They're so toxic.
You started it.
You said they lost to us.
I just said they lost to us, but that didn't mean that they
are bad.
Oh, they're not bad?
Then what does it mean?
Yeah.
We obeyed them.
True.
They're not bad.
Yeah, no, they're not bad.
but we're just better we're just better yeah we should go to
a zone the other team ran away i'm surprised yeah they did
yeah they were so scared find me find me another wingman
here you're out okay okay we'll go um go in inside the zone
first okay yeah yeah i need that actually i need too many
med kits all right i have i have i have like a There's
people in here.
There's people in here.
Okay.
Yeah, I saw a shot there.
I don't have to buy.
I don't know if they're in there, but I saw, like, a
straight shot.
So there was a fight close by.
I think you can do an alt here because you found another
wingman here.
They're far.
They're farther there.
Yeah, do an alt here because there's a wingman here, I'm
pretty sure.
Okay.
You sure?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here, I'll put alt down.
So, Ditto can do another wingman.
Let me see.
There's a team near, by the way.
okay okay no i'm not scared i'm not scared they're like
right above here you know i'm not scared really yeah i'll
put the out down yeah put the ult there i think they're
coming they're coming to us they're coming to us they don't
come here for the all come here for your wingman okay okay
okay okay okay okay get your wingman we can't fight about
your wingman no wingman no wingman oh my okay but i got i
got um this one can we fight this one can we just kill this
guy yeah yeah he's down there sure where is he i i i see one
only one all right let's go let's go make a zip fight them
okay okay yeah yeah i believe in the ditto power that's not
a zip i i think they um he ran away Oh, yeah, zone.
They don't see him.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure they...
Maybe he's...
He's low here, I think.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure he ran to zone.
Or like, he got scared.
He was like girls and then he got scared.
There's one guy here.
Which one?
Oh, over here.
Oh, they're fighting.
Yeah, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Did they shoot us?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I broke one.
Yeah, so I broke one.
Wait, wait, wait.
Go, go, Hiro.
Go, Dittled.
Go!
Wait, is he right here?
Watson 1!
Watson's low, Watson's low!
Okay.
You got Watson?
Nice.
Yeah, I got 1 on it.
Cand?
Flesh!
He's fresh, fresh, fresh.
Yeah, there's this flesh.
Yes, another squad.
Be careful, be careful.
Flesh the guy too.
I'm gonna kill the Watson.
Okay, I will go left.
I will go left.
Wait, there's another guy there.
Okay?
Wait, he went down, he went down.
He went down.
Okay.
Another guy is right here.
He's here.
She's here.
Condu is here.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, they portal.
Portal down.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
They might portal back.
I'm not sure.
There is a someone down here.
They don't.
They went down.
Wait, I see them.
I see them.
Wait, take them back.
Oh my god.
They came back.
They came back?
Oh, there's another team.
They're fighting.
She's back.
In front of me.
Okay.
Right here.
What are they doing?
Wait, they took a portal in here.
I didn't go there.
Yeah, go, go, go, go, go.
I'll go with her.
I'm going with her.
There's a res behind me.
Okay.
I'm going to look at this res.
Where is she?
Where are they?
What the fuck?
What's going on?
Yeah, inside, inside.
Oh.
There's two.
There's a lot of teams.
Oh my god.
There's one team just behind us too.
I'm coming to you.
I'm coming to you guys.
Wait, low, low, low, low, low, low.
Okay.
I'm helping.
I'm trying to help.
Okay, where are you?
I'm getting shot from behind!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, wait, wait.
I got you, I got you, got you.
Okay, I'll keep calling to me.
Yo, wait, wait, wait.
I'm trying to help you.
He's trying to thirst me.
No, he's low.
He's low.
He's not going to.
Wait, no.
No, he's not.
He's not.
Okay, okay, I'm here.
This is the enemy really risky, though.
Oh, I think they're landing.
Are you ready?
They're going another way, yeah.
Okay, what is it, though?
Yeah, bloodhound is low.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Woo!
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You're fine.
Am I?
I have to...
Someone's pushing you.
Someone's pushing you there.
What?
No!
Oh, no!
There's someone pushing us!
They are there!
I'm safe though, I'm safe.
I'm safe, I'm safe.
They're not here, they're not here.
Really?
No.
Can you crawl?
Oh, is that a person over there?
Are you safe?
I don't know.
Okay, I'll go, I'll go to you.
I'll go to her too.
Yeah, no, no, there's two.
There's one person, one person.
One person, two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Wait, there's someone at the
back.
Oh my god, too much!
I can't run.
There's too many.
Only too much.
Oh my god!
Why did he choose me?
What trick is other?
Wait, let's protect each other here.
Yeah, we protect each other.
Oh, we are coming to you, we're coming to you, Ditto.
Ditto, you can craft us, Ditto!
You can craft us!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
We let them let them kill you.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Don't worry.
I will.
Yeah.
Oh, it's okay.
You're almost dead Please kill me Somebody show.
Oh, I'm gonna go to this.
I'm gonna go to this bomb.
No It doesn't kill me.
Oh my god Mookie, please Die Just die.
No Mookie.
Two seconds two seconds.
Wow.
Okay okay i'm dead do you have res beacon where can i i
don't have it i don't have it i i will i will go find it i
will go find it can you though there is so many people how
many people are there a lot okay oh there's eight squads
yeah right okay i will try to get you um We're trying to get
through.
I think I have a red beacon.
I think I have one.
You have.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should go over and see.
I went.
Yeah, I think I have one.
Oh, no.
They're still there.
No, no, no.
They ran.
They rotated.
No, no, they rotated.
No, no.
I just want to see.
You were right.
No, I swear, kid.
They rotated now.
Check, check, check.
Oh my God.
See, they're gone.
They're gone!
I don't want to say a bad word, but are you blind?
What's the bad word?
See, they're gone!
They're gone!
Because of me!
No, they're not!
They told the zip!
Yes!
Are you blind?
Really?
Yeah!
Oh yeah, they're going!
They took a jump pad.
Oh my god, they took a jump pad.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, I have to find out.
Yeah, yeah.
Outside?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, it's outside.
Check in my...
Oh, no, it doesn't.
Where's Jiu-Jitsu?
It's outside!
On the other side!
Yeah, yeah, the other side.
See, they're fighting!
It's your left!
See that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's not mine.
Okay, I got it.
It's mine.
Yeah, you had one too!
You didn't see it!
Wait, I didn't know!
No, no, no!
Why did you shoot?
You could have rest!
I gotta rest!
I gotta rest.
Okay, okay, I gotta rest.
Okay, okay, I trust you.
Oh my god!
Okay, I trust you, I trust you, we're...
Could rest right here?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I don't trust you anymore.
I don't...
Wait, wait, put the rest back in here, put the rest back in
here, slow, it's...
Oh wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You have to leave, though.
You have to leave.
This is not so.
Okay, okay, I will leave.
Goodbye.
Oh my god
She's so good.
Oh my god, see it's me.
I told you You were like the wingman person Wait, oh no, oh
no, oh no, oh no, oh no Oh my god you did it
Congratulations.
Wait.
You did it.
We did it.
Because no he died for us.
I have, wait, what a rank difference.
Wait, let me go back to the lobby.
Bad news.
It says rank difference.
There's rank difference?
Diddle got gone.
Can we play better?
You're too high!
Here, here, you go with Stokoe and rank up to silver.
How did we...
How did you even play one...
Wait, I didn't...
Wait, I...
Did I go to bronze?
Is it not?
You're a rookie.
It's because you're a rookie and like, Dino's gold.
Also, here's 10 subs.
Oh, thank you, Stokoe.
Thanks for the sub.
Thank you.
Don't worry, look.
we'll we'll gain the rp really really fast okay i'm gonna
exit okay all right i did you coach us did oh yeah she can
just watch us and okay okay can someone um share me some um
screen watch our stream watching okay okay coach us okay
okay i will cost you i will cost you guys isn't there like a
delay on stream yeah yeah okay it's okay it's okay really
okay yeah don't worry how wait what rank are you now wait
you just we just need one win your rookie one yeah i'm
rookie one i'm like i'm like almost there i don't even need
to win i think i just need to kill yeah you just need to
kill people okay let's land on somebody then okay yeah how
many points um do you need yeah how many points do you need
uh 100, I think.
It's really easy.
Like, rookie is like, yeah.
That's, like, two to three kills, I think.
Maybe?
No, like, rookie is, like, really, like, any, anything is,
like, 50 points, is it?
Like, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I believe on us, we can do this.
I believe.
He's watching us, so I believe.
Yeah, I would do wash party.
All right, yeah.
Sound guy turned him down a little bit.
yes are you streaming here i'm not streaming right now you
said it was okay okay yeah do you need me to open it on
discord oh yes yes okay okay okay okay okay don't worry let
me do it okay it's okay we're not jump master no this guy
might play like a pussy because he's he's jump master Why?
You don't play like a coward.
Why did you call him pussy?
Because he's not jumping.
Oh, never mind.
No, he is not pussy.
He's thinking it's a fucking fragment.
We're gonna fight, fight here.
We're going to fragment.
Oh, I'm sharing my screen.
Here you go.
Okay.
Oh, no.
We're fight fighting.
Wait, I'm like, my keyboard is wrong now.
Wait, what?
Your keyboard is wrong?
I'm typing in Japanese, wait.
Okay, wait, okay.
It's okay, we're gonna type to.
Wait, he's fighting already!
He's already fighting!
That's what I'm saying!
He's fighting, fighting!
He's not a pussy!
Okay, I'm going.
I'm gonna fight.
Okay, I'm heading over here.
You gotta- There's actually gold knock.
Here.
Oh, wait, that's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need that, actually.
Alright.
Um, um, okay.
Alright, what should we do, coach?
Coach, what do we do?
Just loot!
Loot!
we're not gonna she's she's actually fighting though oh no
we have to help him oh no he's he's oh yeah you have to go
go help i cracked him i cracked him okay nice where is this
other guy at the bottom they're all at the bottom okay oh
nice oh goodbye wait he he's cracked the place that guy's
hello oh there's not at low he's low too i got him nice nice
i'm here
nice nice nice we're so good is that the 100 points already
i have plus 45 by the way we just need a few more and we're
good oh i put heel drone right here you you heal heal heal
force heal yeah yeah i put heel drone here oh my god we yes
coach yes ma'am i did nothing i'm gonna go res i'm gonna res
oh wait i heard somebody really no jk
You can't trust her here.
The only one who can trust is me.
What do you mean?
She's a liar.
I'm not a liar.
Wait, I always say...
I'll kill them.
Watch this.
I'm not a liar.
You're a liar for lying that...
for saying I'm a liar.
You're a liar.
You're lying.
I would never lie.
to you hero i would never lie to you heal you should you
should better um not touch dorky what i'm i'm your healer
you have to trust me i'm your support player okay that guy's
on top you got this hero i believe in you i'm looting really
okay okay i got it yeah yeah you got this look our third is
here now you can be bait wait where is he okay um on on here
I see him.
So you can find the cover and shoot, okay?
I'm finding cover.
I'm lying.
Nice cover.
Oh my god.
Do you see my cover?
If you crack them, you can push.
Oh, okay.
Did we crack them?
A little bit.
Oh my god, really?
Oh, I'm going to push this.
Did you crack them?
No, but...
No, but you push.
No, but I'm going to push.
Yeah, but I killed them.
Nice one.
Yeah, I killed them.
he's flesh nice nice he died oh my god that's sad i
literally don't know how a guy died nice nice see we did it
coach we did it are you good nice points now 50 i i'm 95 oh
95 we just need five more 95 yeah we just need five more
there's a lot find some 95 yeah yeah there's 12 scores left
and it's 95.
oh yeah you're you're even lucky yeah yeah because she's
rookie she gains like a hundred a million points oh we have
five more i wonder how many points you can get like the
maximum like maximum points i think it's like 500 plus
really i'm pretty sure more isn't it more now is it Like, it
was so fast to get out of Rookie.
It literally took, like, two wins.
From, like, nobody here.
There is nobody here.
But, like, ooh!
Yay!
But I can do this.
Oh, what's in the package?
Let's see.
This?
Oh, this.
I need that.
Triple K.
Oh, triple K.
All right, all right.
Rookie, you are lifelike, so you have to give the...
What is that?
The what?
evil harvester to your teammate
see you don't listen to your coach it's just because i'm
just a bad player you're a bad coach
okay you're just a bad coach like like my papa i teach you
how i teach you how how like he um he teach me it's not my
fault you're right it's rpr's but how dare he he's such a
i'm just teaching you like yeah i teach you what she takes i
feel like every time i play with you guys yes wait i'm so
far only only the wait i'm not no i'm not there wait she put
it she put an out down she put an out no what do you mean no
what do you mean no wait i'm here but she's looking at me
i'm gonna put an out down that's fine that's fine that's
She's there!
Okay, Kike, I'm at the portal.
I'm at the portal.
Where are you?
She took the portal!
Oh, she took the portal too!
I'm coming, I'm coming too!
Oh, no!
I got shot by three different people!
No!
Oh, that's her keyword, bitch!
My god!
I'll look if she rises.
I'm gonna look for you if she rises.
Why?
Why are they trying to finish here?
Oh, she read, she read.
No, no, try and finish.
Yeah, bitch.
Oh, now you get 100.
You got 100, right?
From that?
Yeah, I think I got it.
Yeah, yeah, you got it.
You got it.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Yeah, now we can leave.
We can leave now.
That'll be funny.
You're just, like, 1.5.
Please, don't.
No, I'm scared now.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, I'm bronze.
I'm bronze.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, do it.
Join us.
Join me.
All right.
I can join.
I can't.
Okay, where are you?
Why didn't you like send a friend request to Hero while
you're in the lobby?
No, Hero is offline.
You could send a friend request right now.
Oh, she's offline.
Maybe it's your name.
No, she's not.
Liar?
I joined off of her.
It's my life.
See?
Okay, I joined off of her.
My skin shot.
Kara, I will give you my screenshot.
Photoshop.
She's offline.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
So, sound guy turned it down a little bit.
Maybe, maybe English is not the best language to communicate
with Doki.
What language should we use then?
What do you mean?
Maybe we can't use Thai.
I'm communicating!
Wait, YETLI?
Wait, what is... Wait, wait, wait?
YETLI?
What does that mean?
You can ask.
What does that mean, Ditto?
What does that mean?
Motherfucker.
That's the only thing Ditto taught me, though.
Wow!
Ditto's a bad influence.
me to taste you it was a bad influence you asked me you
asked me hilo asked me to teach her is that true hero hi i
don't remember i have no reflection don't remember don't
pretend that she can remember she's just old she's just old
you guys You guys are such an actor.
You are an actor.
It's not true.
I'm not acting.
You guys...
I actually don't remember it at all.
Oh, here, here.
You can't remember.
Yeah, we're just getting bored.
No, no, just like how you didn't remember.
Okay, okay.
You didn't remember?
Oh, okay.
No, no, people.
Oh, I fucked up.
There is.
Where?
Oh, Hiro landed on them.
It's OK.
I'm fine.
I got a gun.
Did somebody press the button?
I fucked up.
Me!
Stay right there.
No, I didn't nobody press the button!
Wait, wait, wait.
They're like right here.
It hits the bottom.
Why didn't nobody press the button?
OK.
I'm going to...
Oh, but that is bottom.
There's the button.
I need to press it.
Right, I don't have the button here.
I'm going over to...
Oh, now... Oh my god, you guys, now you guys...
God, guy, guys!
You fuckers!
No!
Don't look here!
The deep eye here!
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Okay.
There's one guy.
My god, I missed every shot.
Oh my god, you could lie, you know.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
They're shooting you?
Oh yay, they're pushing me!
Okay, I hit Harvard.
Okay, I'm looking for you guys.
It's okay.
They're still not there yet.
Yeah, they're just poking us.
This one's leaving.
Oh, they're leaving?
They're scared.
Wait, they're scared.
You can push, you can push.
Last guy, let's get here.
Last guy's here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're leaving, they're running, they're running.
I'm watching her.
I'm watching too.
I'm trying.
Oh my god!
running running chase chase him okay okay oh no three three
three three three it's three they all oh oh that another
part another team another team we got to go back go back and
loot yeah yeah we have the full place now to loot yeah it's
fun why did they run yeah dude they're not bad why yeah
that's so stupid now we have all the loot why finally
they're scared they're like oh my god they're all gross i'm
so scared oh my god oh my god cuties
average age on apex player oh my god guys cuties girls what
is that that's it Or what is cooties?
Cooties?
Oh, it's a...
It's a disease that girls carry.
And, like, it only infects the boys.
So, like, when we touch a boy, they die.
Ah!
That's cooties.
It's a real disease.
Yeah, it's real.
The doctor says it's like...
There's no cure for cooties.
I see.
There's no cure.
It's very dangerous.
Oh, wingman!
Are you still gonna do it?
No.
Oh.
I think we can fight this team.
Let me...
Wait, can you scan?
Scan?
Scan, okay.
Yeah, okay.
Anyone nearby?
Wait, they're here.
They're right here.
Oh, yeah, I see them.
I see them.
They're really close.
Oh, they want?
Okay, okay.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna...
That is so cute!
White armor!
Nice, nice, nice!
That's so sad.
Oh my god, that poor guy.
He got his streamer mode.
Where's your teammates?
Oh no, the cooties got him.
We gave him cooties.
Oh no!
Wait, let me check if they're still here.
Yeah, they're still here.
This is here.
It has to be.
I'm like, where are they?
Where did they go?
They're so scared.
Okay.
Let me check.
Maybe you can, you can, um, read the people?
Yeah, let me scan.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, people scan.
We've never done that.
I will scan the ring.
Yeah, I'm gonna grab the bat here.
I will go scan the ring.
All right.
It's kind of far.
Maybe they land away.
They are I mean, but he don't still see them Yeah, it's it's
it's they're still here.
Oh, wait, they're gone.
Oh, they're gone.
Oh, okay.
Can can can you scan here?
Yeah, we might as well scan it just in case.
Yeah, I have to keep move closer.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know I'm gonna be here.
Yeah, if you're too far, I'll punch you closer Oh god, don't
punch me in the lava
What do you mean?
I'm at a really dangerous position right now I know God, I'm
so scared Wait, you're actually punching me?
What do you mean?
I would never Okay, they're here They're here There's one
guy over here Do you want to fight Okay, maybe there's a
teammate Yeah, do you want to do sky?
Maybe there's Yeah, oh, okay Let's just do sky hook There's
only one team here In a solo So let's do sky hook Where
should we go?
I want to go sky hook Yeah, yeah, let's go sky hook Wait,
they're fighting?
What's that?
there's like bullets it's one it's a solo is a solo and a
team there yeah and a team yeah so there's no point because
there's a lot of team and i think i'm gonna have a long time
yeah yeah let's go there i'm heading there okay i'm just
taking a little bit of goodies i'm gonna grab some more ammo
all right i'm heading over don't worry front line lifeline
is here okay with front are still fighting or no there was
two there was two in a solo this they did they were two and
they were one team over there too yeah yeah i feel like
we'll bump into somebody they were like three yeah we'll
figure it out when we get there uh i can hear anything i
don't hear anything either in front of me oh that might be
them i'm behind them oh my god in front of me two two two
two Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I knocked one, I knocked
one, I knocked one, I knocked one, did it.
Nice one?
Okay.
They're low.
I knocked two?
I'm going two, I'm going two, I'm going two.
I don't know where the last guy is.
Here, here, here, here, here, the last guy here.
Where?
You guys can do it.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Okay, you got this.
I did my job.
You got it.
Okay.
I already did my job, so it's your turn.
Oh my gosh.
Why were they wearing armor?
That was so close.
But they were white army.
I didn't hear anything.
So they're, like, extra bad.
Why are you white armor?
Maybe they just, um, revive?
No, you revive, you get your armor.
That's the thing.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You still get your armor.
Wait, wait, not the team, not the team.
In front of you?
Oh, where?
Oh, okay, there.
Run, huh?
Okay, unrun, huh?
Okay, I'm...
Oh, it's not serious, okay.
Yeah, I'm pushing.
Oh, my God, I'm pushing toes.
Oh, my God.
Okay, wait, I'm not.
I believe you did oh I'm shooting I'm shooting I'm shooting
I can't I don't stop shooting I don't stop shooting you're
shooting you're shooting I'm shooting you got it you got it
there's grenades I got him I got one okay okay okay I'm bad
I'm badding I'm badding okay okay there are two two left one
left one left one left I can't count she's here you got this
here it's your turn we got our ones she's running to you
guys she's one running to us you got this here I'm gonna
loot No, no, let Hiro kill her.
Let Hiro.
Yeah.
I just want...
I just wanted to see...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just want to watch you cry.
We each got our ones.
Okay.
Nice.
I like Ditto's comms.
Never stop shooting.
Don't...
No reload.
Just shoot.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, nice.
You didn't give Hiro purple?
I'm so fucked.
Why?
You're not a team player.
If I didn't take it, you would gonna take it.
That's not true.
No.
That's true.
You did.
You did it before.
No, that's not true.
I did it to you, but I won't do it to Hiro.
No.
I'm running away.
It's okay.
I'm too sad.
Kilo will understand me.
You're sad right now.
What do you mean?
I'm gonna, I'm just gonna be on my, on my drone next.
Sorry, time.
She's not sad.
She's sad.
Please not.
Ditto, why did you, why did you hit her?
Ditto, why didn't you hit her, Ditto?
You're in the open.
You're in the open here.
Okay, Ditto often does this to me.
Oh, Ditto, why would you do it?
do that you're so that's so fun I'm literally I'm on the
grass oh my god I'm so fucked up you know I'm so poor hero
she's getting a bleed she can she can get um purple armor
herself you know what I'm just gonna stand I'm gonna stand
right here come here doggy come here why do I have to come
here Why?
Why me?
Come on!
She's dead.
There's two squads.
It's here.
Why me?
Why?
We have to come here.
Only one.
Only one here.
I'm getting shot at.
I'm getting back.
I cracked.
Okay.
I cracked him.
Why didn't you go out?
Why didn't you go?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, behind, behind, behind, behind, behind, behind.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, she's hiding.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, okay.
What the fuck, please?
He's not alone.
I'm...
Guys, I'm giving you guys.
I'm getting cyberpunk.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Okay, go again.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
What the fuck?
Who?
Wait, there's a charge rifle over there!
I don't!
Can you finish that?
I can't!
Okay, I will finish them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll sit here and document me.
Oh my god, this team is so annoying!
They are, they are.
There's three squads, though.
They are very annoying.
Oh my god.
I'm scared, Hiro.
I'm scared.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where?
Got it.
On my ping?
On a container?
Yeah.
We should kill this team Which one?
Yeah, oh, they're pushing the push.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Crack crack crack crack crack You got it.
I got him.
Okay.
We can we can fly We can fly really far.
He's like over there.
There's another team.
Can you thirst him?
Oh, yeah, here here.
Where is here?
Here on the ping on the ping.
I don't see a ping.
Oh, there he is.
Okay Yeah, on car.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I'm looking looking at crosses I don't see him.
Where are they?
Where?
No, no, I'm looting.
I'm looting?
It's over here.
Allow here.
All right.
I'm coming over here.
Wait, on me, on me, on me, on me, on me, on me.
Crack, crack, crack, crack, crack.
On here, on here.
Behind this box, behind this box.
On far.
I cracked him, though.
Broke, broke.
Nice.
I'm crossing.
One hit, one hit.
I know.
Not past finder.
This one hiter.
I knocked him.
This one's one too.
This one's one.
Yeah, but he's like blocking him for me.
I got him.
got him nice pull dead pull dead right here right here right
here oh my god okay okay okay okay okay okay okay i got the
gaps on oh i i saw purple purple polymer over here up top
okay okay okay oh my god i need oh we go together okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay all right go dino go honestly
honestly i'm going i'm going i'm going you can't die quack
quack quack Oh god, I can't see.
I'm having you watch.
Red armor, red armor.
Oh god.
Okay, I need a backup from that.
Oh!
Okay.
I am healing.
I'm healing.
In front, in front, in front, in front of here.
In front of here.
Over here, over here.
I'm taking the zip.
Okay.
I'm doing something crazy.
Okay, I have only one battle.
Oh my god, my god.
That one, that one's, where's one hit, Ditto?
Yeah.
I want okay.
I'm kind of getting cross.
I didn't cross.
I have one.
Okay, nice.
I'm trying to...
I got one, I got one, I got one!
Okay, okay, inside, inside the...
Okay, inside the...
Okay, watch, watch, watch!
I will go help, I will go help the...
Help me, help me, help me, I got one, I got the other.
Last guy, last guy, last guy, last guy.
Okay, last guy there, last guy there.
Cracked him, I cracked him!
I want your shit.
Give me your shit.
Hey, hey!
Yay!
All right.
Look at us go.
We're so good now.
Where's this guy?
Okay, I'm like, I don't have...
I almost have no more...
I don't have...
I don't have anything.
Yeah, we're poor now.
We're so poor on y'all.
Oh, where?
Where?
They're coming to us.
Oh, okay, okay.
I see him.
Wait, they also have a bow.
Wait, I need his bow.
I almost have no more bow.
Give me your shit.
Let me go look at them.
Be careful here.
Let me... You know what?
I'm gonna e-mп a bit.
Oh.
Don't wait, my drone is coming back.
Okay.
Okay?
I'm getting on the roof.
Okay, I just got my up.
Oh, I got 100 with my...
Oh, nice, nice, nice!
Ooh, careful.
Yeah, yeah, get the rampart away.
Get the rampart away.
I'm doing it now, I'm doing it now.
Okay, I'm slowly heading over.
Okay.
Alright.
Be careful and be careful.
I'm doing it now!
We got siege!
Resourt!
I got gnosh!
Wait, you got gnosh?
Yo!
All right, all right, back up.
I have to back up.
Can you keep crawling back to me?
Crock back to us.
Okay.
I think I can't.
Oh no, okay, okay, okay.
All right, you cover, you cover.
I'm gonna go grab her.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I have to, I actually have to bat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're getting crossed.
They're getting across right now.
Oh, they see me heading.
Cover, cover, cover.
Oh.
She, she, she, there's some, there's a, there's a behind.
Maybe you have, maybe you have, yeah, yeah.
to kill them first I got it one got it I got it Oh they
killed me He got you Wait Keep on max I'm trying I'm trying
I'm trying But I need you to Cover though Okay okay Yeah You
can do it Okay they have I think this is one It's a Solo And
then this team Yeah So And Oh This is bad They're on me
They're on me The Solo's on me No this is a No no Don't let
me, don't let me, don't let me Pass away the person alone
One knock, one knock And one another one with heal I don't
know where he is He's here Okay I got him, I got him I got
him I got him Nice, nice You should do that solo It's okay,
okay, it's okay Here Here There is, there is Wait, they're
not solo, this isn't solo This is not a solo?
It's not a solo?
It's not a solo.
It's a full team just waiting.
The full team ratting.
Oh no.
Please die!
I almost got him too!
Oh it's a full team!
It's a full team ratting!
Cowards!
They're actual cowards!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I can't believe the full team ratting!
And they lose.
They lose a lifeline.
They lost.
I can't kill.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe much.
Nice.
I can't believe a full team.
Ratted.
We were like mowing down.
We killed everybody in this team.
Ratted.
I was like, wait, that's not one person.
Yeah.
Wait, didn't we?
again i got dc oh yeah dc dc dc yes yeah do you want to be
leader do you want to be leader i can't join why i can't i
can't join anyone i invited to i'm waiting okay i will i
will play horizon because um password is too high hard i got
headshot um with that um bossy oh no oh no
yeah i mean his hitbox is like bigger his hitbox is bigger
it's okay this time this time you won't die this time i
believe yeah yeah here do you believe in ditto i believe
yeah i believe
3 this time.
Yeah, yeah.
Ditto.
Ditto, you're going to 1v3.
Why?
Why you guys want me to 1v3?
Because you're prepped.
You're so cool.
You played 2.
Ditto, I 1v3'd.
Where was your last game?
I literally 1v3'd.
What do you mean?
You're prepped 2.
Yeah, and I 1v3'd.
Where was your 1v3?
Yeah?
Ditto?
what did it was your 1v3 I just won v3 last game which game
last game I literally won v3 last game no you didn't you
didn't what do you mean you didn't kill that live by I
killed oh sorry I didn't I killed which one I killed three
people in the with the costume you killed two I killed two
three i killed two and i damaged i broke one armor all right
dido your turn on one v3 right did you just did one witchy
i'm not saving your life anymore dido no remember the bridge
the bridge did you remember the bridge i saved your life
No, I did knock one What you mean, I killed I saved your
life I killed two and I let you knock the third
He was just here to watch No, I'm like Okay, okay Who's
right He was just like If I say anything, they're gonna turn
on me I was scared You know Scary Scary Dorky, no, you're
gaslighting me again.
I had...
You're lying.
You're gaslighting me.
I know what I did.
Last match.
Yes, I did.
Wait, there's somebody there, Dorky.
Oh, there is?
I did it.
One B3, it's time.
Okay.
It's time.
She's there, actually there.
Wait, wait, wait.
Watch this.
let's see!
Three?
T, together?
Inside the building?
No.
He can do it.
Not together.
Oh, my
God.
I down one?
Oh, no.
He's slow, he's slow, he's slow.
Nice.
I down one.
Okay, okay.
I'm here.
I'm here, I'm down one.
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Flash, flash!
20, I hit like 80...
Yeah!
Hiro 1, 3!
Hiro 1v3!
Hi, 1v3!
Oh, yeah, you guys!
You guys play all play together I will just watch I will
just watch you guys 1v2 people Okay What do you mean?
Where's your 1v3?
Why?
Why not?
Why do I have to play?
If you guys can 1v2 every team Because we gotta show
everybody That we can each individually 1v3 I can I can 1v3
Then show me Where's the enemy Yeah Alright next Where's the
enemy?
Next enemy, next enemy, you're gonna...
Wait, there's actually sound here, but do we?
Oh yeah, yeah, it's time, it's time to know!
Why do we have to warn with cheap people?
We have cheap people!
Why do we have to play solo?
Because each of us needs to show that we're good at the
game, okay?
And we want to prove that people...
We're actually fighting really hard right now.
Yeah, and we want to prove to people that we are a Pred girl
squad.
We each have the 1v3 at least once today Wait dude, he's
right here.
He's right here.
It's time.
Don't don't don't help her.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'll scan for you Ditto.
Here we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, only one You see it wait he's coming it's the bottom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Look I'm following him.
I'm following him No, I did one with you.
I killed one team.
Yeah You did it, Ditto!
You did it!
I did it!
Oh wait, no, no!
Oh wait, one only!
One only, one only here!
You keep killing one!
Yeah, yeah, yes, here, here, here, here.
There's no other bloodhound here too.
Yeah, yeah, there's only one guy here.
Yeah, yeah, you keep killing one!
He's looting!
Yeah, go, go, go, go!
Go, Ditto, go!
No, no!
Oh wait, another team, not the team.
Oh, oh, I dropped down, I dropped down, I dropped down.
I cracked him, I cracked him.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Oh, it's the same team.
Oh, wait, alright, alright.
that's his teammate okay i'm gonna this is a different team
yeah this is different okay okay okay it's okay it's okay
army army i'm here wait we're here yeah they're here almost
okay almost okay oh my god he's cracked oh my god i don't
like them i will kill them you can do it you know you can do
it if you kill two that's a 1v3 see he's so low that guy by
the way he's not low The lifeline.
Oh my god, he's coming out the cart.
This one guy here.
Alright, Ditto, Ditto.
He got him low, Ditto.
I got him low.
I got the Bloodhound low.
It's your turn.
1v3.
He's so low.
Now you need two more.
One more, one more, Ditto.
One more.
I broke it.
I broke it for you, Ditto.
1v3!
Yeah!
We did it!
One with three!
Okay, okay!
Okay, we did!
One with three!
Yeah!
See guys, we're good at this game.
We each can 1v3.
Each of us can 1v3, guys.
We're a pro squad.
Oh my god.
Another squad, another squad.
Yeah.
Here, I'll even beat them.
Go, Doki!
You can do it.
Wait, now we can play as a team.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Now we can play as a team.
Okay, okay.
As a team, okay?
Yeah, yeah.
Where is she?
Okay.
it at us yeah yeah now that we show everyone how we're good
individually now we show people how we're good as a team
okay enemy oh sorry wait there's another team here you go go
go go yes just one there's an ash uh there's an ash back
over here because they did a nice thing it's conduit it's
conduit and he's white armor he's white armor yeah i broke
him don't worry i will follow him follow him follow him
don't let him run you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna jump
tower yeah i think you're so far from us he's so low really
long oh he's here he's here he's here i'm running i'm
running i'm running he's here here here okay okay here how
low is he he's dead oh wait he has a team oh wait wait i'm
gonna finish him i'm gonna finish him all right where's your
team okay okay okay
Okay, they're racing.
Okay, I will go.
I will go back.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm scared.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, I got there.
No, come here.
Wait, you see it.
Yeah, they snare you.
Come here, come here, come here.
It's Ash.
Wait, did he throw that all the way from there?
Is that Ash?
White armor.
White armor?
Two people here.
It's Ash.
Yeah, he fucking snared me all the way back here.
He's here, he's here, he's here.
He's here.
Here, here, here, here.
He has to come to me watch this.
Wait, he out here?
Oh, he out there.
Oh, wait, that's a good off.
Wait, wait, another one here.
Another one here.
Oh, Ash, you made a mistake.
Okay, I feel his teammate.
I made a mistake, he's over there.
I waited too long.
Crazy.
His port, he's like, he ran.
Go kill them.
I'm running.
Let me check for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where did he go?
Yeah, where did he go?
He doesn't have his ult anymore.
He's here!
He's so far!
He's just too far.
No, I'm gonna chase him.
You can't run away from me.
Okay.
You guys go left side!
Yeah, yeah.
You guys go left side.
And cut him off.
I'll go there.
Yeah, you guys cut him off.
He has to to go here he has to rotate here i think i think
he's gonna carve um his teammate banner again did they have
a crafter for him it was call it does kano wait oh shit i
forgot one team guys wait wait guys guys i fucked up guys
guys i'm ready doggy why me tree don't you want me tree guys
guys i'll go to you i i'll go to you i'll go to you I got
her donkey, I got her I got her I got her It's okay, it's
okay, it's okay Here, here, here Really fast robot Guys, I
fucked up Why, what happened?
What happened?
I got hunted
With full squad?
Yeah, that was a full squad Oh here, here, here, here, here
Wait, they're fighting Ditto okay fighting with me they're
fighting with me oh maybe we have to go there all right you
know i'll emp them for you diddo oh yeah we can do it we can
do it okay are we fighting are there right you on the fight
you're on the fight yeah all right we're gonna fight in zone
then yeah here here here here all right i'm heading over i
crack one i don't have an angle she's there yeah i see see
them i see them you use your horizon cue i'm gonna nice
flash flash one splash one splash yeah there's one's almost
low i got one i got one all dead all dead all dead all dead
see we did it as a team okay we're good as a team and
individual guys it's kind of painful okay oh wait just wait
wait a minute what they have a wait a minute what wait do
you have a do you have do you have a heat shield cookie yeah
yeah i have heat shield wait oh my god you're both so far
from each other wait wait
Oh my god, this is lagging!
Wait, the zone hurts, guys!
What is that?
I'm lagging!
The zone hurts!
The zone is not good.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh my god, the zone is really hurt!
Yeah, the zone really hurts!
Wait, so far!
We don't have a...
I know, that's why it's like we're fighting?
I have only one hit you And don't get she's using Hit you
for herself I'm dying I only have I have one to win Yeah
yeah yeah I have one lip I have one lip too Oh no I might
die I might die before I could head over Wait did it oh my
god I don't have heals Wait I'm gonna die Oh no Oh my god No
I'm so close I used me last year.
I'll give you a little bit of heal here.
Oh wait, I don't have a heal.
Okay, y'all.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna say it.
He was first heal.
He did 30 seconds.
Oh my God, I made it, I made it, I made it, I made it.
Goodbye guys.
You're so dead.
I love dead.
Goodbye, everybody.
Are they there?
Oh, I don't know, but I'm running.
I don't know, but I'm running.
I need it Oh my god Zone Guys Oh my gosh Yeah Yeah the zones
hurt I'm not gonna make it Am I gonna I don't know Oh okay
We've got a run Kill a run Wait there's a red In front of us
There's a red There's a red It's okay It's okay I'm looking
I'm looking Ready Team here Team here I think we go We go
left Just on Yeah Left, left, left.
I go to you.
Yeah, but there's a res right here though.
Okay.
We have to go right then.
No, one team on the right.
Wait, we go here.
We go here.
I can EMP.
Okay, okay, okay.
We can go from the...
Yeah.
We can go from the bottom.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're over here.
That's okay.
They don't see us.
They don't see us, but they saw me!
They saw me!
It's okay, it's okay.
careful here i have i have cute i have cute i have okay okay
okay guys guys yes guys guys this is bad this is oh oh god
guys okay okay okay we're so healthy we're okay stay here
stay here this is safe this is safe oh my god it's okay
We're so safe.
We're okay.
We're coming over.
I'm coming over.
Do you want to go to the third?
Okay, I want his armor.
We're okay.
Where?
He's small, can't.
I'm coming over.
I'm queuing.
I dropped one down.
I dropped down.
Wait, I dropped down too.
Down.
Ditto, Ditto!
Ditto!
He's cack, he's cack.
I can't, we can't get up.
No, they're raising.
He's raising, he's raising.
I don't have kill.
Go, go, go.
He raised, he raised, he raised.
In the, in the heart.
Crack, crack, crack.
Okay, okay.
He's low, he's low.
He's down?
Nice.
But he has to, zone, zone, zone, we run, we run, we run,
zone, zone, zone!
Okay.
Zone hurts, zone hurts.
Leave him, leave him, leave him.
The zone hurts.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, I will carve my ammo.
I need a battery.
This zone hurt!
Okay, okay.
I will get keeping them.
Yeah, we can keep, we can keep.
Okay, I'll get keep later.
Yeah, they have to die.
They have to die here.
There's no way.
Wait, they have a- Wait, they have a- They're gonna die
anyway.
They're gonna die anyway.
Yeah, yeah, they're gonna die.
that be careful are they where where are they where did they
go wait there's someone here where did he go his creeper no
are they they died no no what i i didn't i didn't go here i
don't get a kill yeah i don't get a kill too where did they
go they lived what oh no they got Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Bruh, Gibby all.
Wait, this creeper, creeper here.
There's a Gibby all in front of me.
Be careful, be careful, be careful, dokie.
I know, I know, but there's a Gibby all in front of me.
Yeah, but, um, they did.
They did.
They all did.
No, no, no, no, I didn't.
We didn't get a kill.
I get, I got a kill.
I got a kill.
You did.
Oh, I got two kills.
Oh, you got two kills.
What the?
Oh, they come to me.
They come to you?
Okay.
They come to you.
It was solo.
That was...
There's another one.
There was solo.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
The potions?
Be careful.
First floor?
I'm going up.
No, that's me.
That's me.
I was on first floor.
Hitoki?
Okay, thank you.
Now we are on TVT.
They have Kaleva.
Where are they?
I have EMP.
Over here.
Almost here.
Okay.
There's like a solo over there too.
I want to kill solo.
If we crack, we can push that building.
Wait, you want our EMP.
Our EMP enough.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah, this guy is so over there.
Your EMP, I will queue up.
Yeah, we're heading over.
We're heading over.
Okay, she here.
Okay, okay.
I will queue up.
Yeah, I'm right here.
I'm with you.
He's right below us?
Yeah, on the third floor?
I'm not there.
Whoa, that guy's solo.
That guy right here.
Oh, it's me, it's me, it's me.
I'm over, I'm over.
Nice.
Thirst him, thirst him, thirst him.
Okay.
I got the bat, I got the bat, I got the bat.
Thirst him, I got the bat.
Where is his teammate?
Here, here, here.
I'm pushing.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, here, here, here, here, here, here, here, here, here,
here, here, here, here.
No, last guy here, last guy.
That's the creeper guy.
Okay, I'm going to punch him.
I'm going to punch him.
Yeah, punch him.
Punch him.
Yeah, oh, guys, guys.
Yeah, look, we 1v3 that entire game, and also we played as a
team.
We punched, yeah.
Yeah.
Girl Prince, girl Prince Call us the cootie squad We did 20
kills again Let's go We're the cootie squad We touch them
and they die The cootie squad Yeah, we're the cootie squad
he's cool
we have cooties actually yeah we have cooties you don't want
to get touched we all have cooties yeah we all have cooties
when we shoot a person they die that's why we punched them
all together we gave him we gave him um extra cooties
because we touched him yeah yeah punches is like more It's
more fatal.
You die faster
God skin to skin contact is it Skin contact yeah
Kooties are always fatal guys, but we make it faster when we
punch you when you get punched It's like uh-huh.
It's like you die in one day you die in one hour if you get
punched We die in one hour yeah and then the punch it's like
the punches stack so the more punches you get the faster you
die like if you get black yeah if you get punched by all
three of us you die in one second oh yes yes yeah that was
that was that was really fast yeah it's like poison damage
it stacks You know, like...
The multiplier.
Hey, hey.
Here we go again.
Yeah, yeah.
This was our winning area.
We won over there.
Oh, one team.
One team.
The Kootie squad is here.
The Kootie squad.
Oh, they're there with us.
They're there with us.
Whoa!
Only two!
Wait, where is his third?
Oh, I hear the Valk.
I hear the Valk.
i'm gonna go kill them yeah yeah yeah i hear in my hand they
they're flying they're flying where did they go they took
the tower took the oh yeah they're gone yeah oh my god they
went they're here they're here they're here oh okay i i oh
my god okay you guys got this i'm getting the i'm getting
the crate nice okay i got it Where did they go?
Oh, okay.
Over there, I think.
I'll scan them.
Okay.
Yeah, they do here.
I'm going to...
I will go with this car.
I'll scan them for you.
Whoa, there's me.
I'm going to grab this longbow.
I will scroll first.
Only one, only one here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm heading over.
Where's his teammate?
Whoa, where is the teammate?
Another building.
Oh, oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
It's a Loba.
Loba, yeah, yeah.
The Loba queued over here.
He's on the roof now.
I'm here.
It's still, it's still, it's still.
It's still, it's still.
Okay.
I'm gonna calm up.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm heading over.
Oh, it's... Oh, Ditto!
Oh, me!
Join me, join me.
Lobo is...
Lobo is okay.
Lobo, loo, loo, loo.
Lo, loo.
One hit.
She's ready?
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
I fucked up.
I fucked up, guys.
They got less.
You, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
You guys can 1vc.
Are you safe?
Yeah, I'm safe.
I'm safe.
You're not.
You're not safe.
Oh, no.
No.
You are not safe!
Kill him!
Wait, wait, kill me!
Kill me!
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no, no.
Look at this, look at this.
I'm gonna grab you.
Isn't that too hard?
Oh my god, thank you.
Are you close enough?
No!
Yeah, I'm just waiting for them to do.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay, they didn't see, they don't see.
Oh no, now they know, now they know.
We have to go!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Wait, wait, wait?
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
It's okay, just res me and then we craft her later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I lost my gold gun.
Where's the gear?
Here?
Um, yeah.
Yeah, the dome?
Yeah, just res me here and then craft me late.
Craft her late.
What happened?
What happened to you?
I climbed the wrong thing and then I slid it was like a
slide I thought you were with me I thought I was there I was
there but you know I was like one I thought so too No I lost
my gold gun I'm so sad I'll go rest I lost my gold long
phone It's okay It's okay there's no one gabiolong We can't
go back.
Why would no one grab it?
It's such a good gun.
Why is no one use longbow?
What do you mean it?
It's a good gun.
Wait, there's someone here.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Okay.
He's like right here.
Oh yeah.
There's only one guy.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Okay.
Maybe we can go, um, line side.
Line?
Line side.
Go back.
and go back okay go to the waterfall oh it's not yeah what's
there is there oh guys in it um okay how about lunch light
lunch light wait okay let me let me check um are they still
there they're all there that way they don't you lie to me
you see nobody
they used your longbow they're using my longbow liar what oh
my god i can't i i can't leave their mind i can't why was
the closest craft there's no crafters here like what yeah
has there nothing the closest what's there wait there's
someone here what the hell we run backwards they don't they
They don't see you.
I think we can.
Wait, wait.
Wait.
This is a scary game.
This is a horror game now.
Wait, they're right above us, I think.
Oh my god.
You guys.
Oh no.
They scat us.
We have to go up.
Really?
Ah!
The fuck!
The fuck?
yeah they don't know you're there they don't know here it's
okay it's okay it's okay they don't know they don't know
they don't know they don't know they don't know they don't
know they don't know yeah what the is this area they don't
know but they have a bloodhound yeah yeah they don't know
but they have a bloodhound no they're not gonna scan they're
not gonna scan your way you have to Wait, maybe you can run.
Maybe you can't run here now.
Can you?
Yeah, run left.
Run left.
Wait, they're like right next to me though.
Wait, they are?
But they're fighting.
Oh no, another team.
Another team, another team, yeah.
Oh my god.
Just hit the fragment.
Just the closest craft, no harvester.
Just craft us in harvester.
That's literally the closest craft.
We have to go there.
Yeah.
You're... Okay, jump, jump tower.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, jump tower!
Oh wait, I...
Here, you can do it!
Be a hero!
You don't... I'll go there?
Yeah, that's good, that's good.
I like, Kali, we just never leave this place so you don't
know we're here forever.
Yeah, and then you craft this and then you quick-quick-res
us.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you get to the same
area.
You know what?
I can... I can...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Over there, over there.
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna sit in the truck.
Okay, I swear if somebody could...
Okay.
Bro, that's so dangerous.
Don't worry about it.
Trust him.
You like suddenly just stop, like you're...
Okay!
Zero team!
Zero teams, zero teams.
That's good, that's good.
That's good!
Hero!
It's our hero!
Oh my god!
It's so scary.
I saw one team, by the way.
Oh no.
I'm not sure it's his one team.
It says one.
We're back guys.
We're back.
Okay.
Here, I took a harvester for you too.
Oh, nice.
Okay, okay.
I'm back.
We're back guys.
It's like we never died.
You know what?
I'm thinking respawn beacon with me.
Oh yeah, that's smart.
That's so...
That's really smart.
We definitely need that.
We're a mess right now.
I'll like sell.
Oh, I'll give you another I'll like sell too.
here oh yeah i might as well crowd yeah let's see i'll do it
just to get us a package we need a package so badly yeah
yeah we need a package all right oh wait what wait wait wait
wait wait oh i hear my here my team i'm gonna emp them i'll
emp them oh i hear them i'm gonna excel oh never mind never
mind i'm gonna help okay is that yours it's like oh that's
not you wait that's not me you they're right here i thought
that was you for some i didn't shoot him because i was like
hey wait don't worry i have not there's not me i have my
respawn be okay leave ditto okay and then and then i'm
trying i'm trying to leave i'm really i'm trying i'm trying
right now she's having a good position i thought that was i
the the crypto made me think The enemy rave was you for some
reason.
Okay, I got her.
How are you alive?
Okay, res me time.
I was scared to scan me there.
Oh no, it's okay, it's okay.
They don't know.
Dido, are you close to a res?
Yeah.
Yeah, you res me.
Dido, let's get a res.
Don't, Kiro, you just see it live.
They might see you on top here though.
They're on top here.
It's okay, just okay.
They don't hear her.
really yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm sure you you still don't just
you don't don't you don't no i'm i i don't try stalking they
saw me they saw me they don't die so they don't die so you
don't keep taking
no no you die first you die first okay okay
you're alive though you're alive do you have beacon i do i
do have a beacon but there's somebody here no no you you
like you um wait there's a local market no no no you know
what to do you oh i said you should have just get your drone
out of rest is back there really yeah don't do it do it so
do it wait zero teams no team okay okay never mind let's
let's go oh that's good we're so back we're so back guys
okay we're so back Guys, everything's fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm back.
Yeah, I told you guys, we're so bad.
Wait, there's no solo.
There's a solo near us.
Which one?
Here.
Oh, yeah, here, here.
We both kill them.
Both kill them.
Yeah, look.
He's here.
Here, here, here, here.
Right here, right here.
I'm going.
Right here.
The box.
Hello.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
No, he's...
Wait, the ring.
Oh, they ate a ring.
There's loba, there's loba, loba.
Have him run so we can have his loot when he dies.
He's gonna take the geyser.
No, we can't take the loot though!
No, he went to the door.
Another team here.
Yeah, another team.
They're trying to keep us.
They're trying to keep keeping us.
Oh no.
I think we can kill this guy.
Okay.
He's low.
Oh my god, he's so low.
He's so low.
Oh, EMP.
Ditto, Q.
Okay, okay.
You guys do that.
Q up, Q up, Q up, Q up.
Let's go, let's go.
I'm going up, I'm going up.
How to kill this team.
Where?
Over here.
From here.
Behind me.
Nice.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
Last guy, last guy.
Oh, I can't see.
I can't see what the...
Wait, I broke it?
No, I'm so bad with a flatlight iron sight.
Nice.
This is bad.
Okay.
This is very bad for me.
I'm very bad.
I got hit by the fuse.
Oh, you had gold.
Yep.
That's good.
Let me check.
I'll recover.
He's here.
Okay, okay, I need to get rid.
I will kill him.
Okay, nice.
What are you looking at?
I need loot.
Huh?
What are you looking at?
Yeah.
That's right.
Cracked him!
Do you have health?
No, no, no, no, no.
There's team to our left looking.
There's team to the left looking at us.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, I have to find the attachment.
We have a good spot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Team here, I'm looking...
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Two teams fighting now.
I'm just kidding, okay.
Yeah, we can go there.
Okay Oh, I'm gonna check.
I'm looking can you can you MP them?
No, I just need you sure to use it.
I will need I will need I will need to what the fuck?
There's a different team.
There's a different team there I knocked one not nice on me
on me on me on my door.
I finished them.
I finished them Flash flash nice nice nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we okay.
We take this building.
Yeah, this is our building bitch Yeah, yeah, this is our
building bitch.
Yeah, oh my gosh Be careful, be careful, be careful.
That's scary, that's scary.
Oh, whoa.
You scared.
Wait, what?
Where are they?
Classic crack, classic crack here.
Flash?
Not flash, sorry I lied.
Not flash, not flash, what do you flash?
Okay, okay.
Another one inside the building.
This is crack.
Okay.
I'm going up, I'm going up.
I'm batting, okay.
I'm going to you, I'm going to you.
I got him, I got him, they're over here.
Over here?
They're getting shot, they're getting shot at.
Okay, another team, be careful.
Yeah, I cracked them, I cracked them.
Okay?
Yeah, yeah, they're cracked.
We can't fight, we can't fight.
I almost have EMP.
Yeah, yeah, let's wait for EMP.
I have Ood.
Okay, where do you want me EMP?
I'm gonna loot.
Yeah, now I'm just like you guys.
There's a gold breast here for you, Hiro.
Maybe they're lazy.
I'm not I'm not sure I don't know either Here oh here here
we gotta get the zone though I would okay.
Oh yeah, I have to get we have to get the zone Yeah, with
the zone we might get gate kept here Where's the where's the
other team?
I don't know.
That's the scary part I don't know There there okay over
there.
So that means we can push up here We are we are not inside
it.
Yeah, we have to figure out how to We need to figure out
where to go.
We can't we can't take this this place.
Okay, yeah We didn't stand here.
Yeah but...
Maybe it's 14 Black.
Let me scan them.
Yeah yeah yeah, yeah.
Be careful.
Maybe if...
I'm looking.
Here, here, here, here.
Here, here, here.
Oh okay.
Oh!
They're hiding!
Here!
There's one here.
There's one here, too.
Look.
Oh!
I'm batting I'm batting.
They're all, they're blue armor.
They're not that strong.
This is three people with a solo.
Wait, this is solo!
No, it's Chi.
And not one.
I'm gonna go.
I'm doing something stupid.
I got one.
Okay.
Oh, cracked.
Wait, someone stay high ground.
Someone stay high ground.
Dead, dead.
Oh, wait.
One more.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Dead, dead, dead, dead, dead.
He's here.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm pushing.
Okay, me too.
I'm pushing too.
You can push.
Oh, all red, all red.
I'm batting, I'm batting any cover, you know.
Oh, he's out.
Don't land on me.
Low, low, low, low, low.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ooh, Ditto died!
Hey!
Look at guys!
Look how good!
Even though we...
Ditto and I died...
Like a champion!
Yeah, we...
Even Ditto and I died like six times?
We died a lot.
I died a lot in the club.
MVP, you know, it's MVP.
You're MVP.
No, no, no, no.
Thanks for this, yeah.
This is like, res.
You tell Hiro was just reshing us.
Crypto's really fun now, though.
You can't run away from cooties.
It's like, you know, like those like, no, it's just like the
sanitizers.
It kills 99% of germs.
And then Hiro's the 1% that lives.
you might kill 99% of cooties but this isn't the 1% will
bring us back so I can't respond because so great I can't
believe we won that oh shit we should not have won that The
first part where Doki fell in the lava.
I kind of want to see what happened, actually.
You know, like, I like, I climbed...
So, you guys...
So, like, I climbed the one area that you can't climb.
And then I slipped down.
I, like, got up and then I slide down.
And then, like, Dito and I were fighting on top of it.
I was like, I'll show you.
I'll show you.
If you land here, I'll show you where I climb.
Okay.
Wait, there's like three teams.
Maybe a lot.
Yeah.
No, we can do it.
I think we should go here.
I think we should go here first.
Okay, I'm with the team of us.
There's a team of us.
One team, one team.
Yeah.
I will grab a gun.
Okay, you grab it?
Yeah, I got a gun.
Me too.
Okay, good.
I don't have it.
You're on this way?
I'm heading over.
Oh, that's a mirage.
I'm here, Ditto.
I don't know where the- Nice.
I forgot where the other guy is.
He's also here.
Yeah, I hear him.
On my left?
Oh, they have 220.
Oh, here!
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
Yeah, why did he...
Why did two flock?
What?
I mean, okay.
I'll take that.
Oh, my God, he's so cute.
He's like...
He's so cute.
Thank you.
What's the orders of...
oh my god that's the mirage clone yeah let me let me let me
check let me check he wanted a hug here um for like wait oh
where's the mirage here here here here here here here here's
the mirage here yeah i think the teammate ran yeah i think
you ran the craft yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty sure because the
mirage can craft yeah yeah not here yeah yeah i don't think
so let me check let me and there's one here okay bloodhound
all right oh yeah with me with me oh with you they didn't
run yeah huh it's bangalore oh wait i think she's running
now i think she's running yeah now she's running i'm gonna
check the other make sure the other team doesn't push us on
the jump tower you guys got i believe oh they're fighting oh
my god they're so low There are two teams here.
Oh wait.
Wait, I got her.
Oh, you guys are nice.
It's so good.
Oh my god, I really want to shoot so badly.
Nice, nice, nice.
They're pushing.
I'm gonna watch.
Nice job.
I'm here.
They're right here.
They're pushing.
I'm going to charge.
Oh, they're fighting.
Okay, I got reload a little bit.
Okay.
They fuse also.
Oh yeah.
Full fight, full fight, full fight.
Okay, full fight I'm gonna donate Okay, okay My name Yeah,
he's so low Okay, I'll Okay, I'm here now I'm here now No, I
have to reload Holy shit Oh my god, please Holy shit How did
my life Okay, I need heal I thirsted the the I'm thirsty, a
bloodhound, you want armor swap.
Yeah.
I'm thirsty.
You guys got it.
On me?
Okay, give me a say.
Wait, I don't have shield.
Oh, thank god, another team!
Oh god, another team?
Okay, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
Oh my god!
Alright.
Holizen?
I need loot.
Sorry, I don't have shield.
With me?
Okay, yeah, I'm coming over.
Where are you?
Okay.
Oh, Ditto, you're so far!
You're so far!
Okay.
I got...
Oh, I don't have any ammo!
Say it!
I got the gold bag Only one left Only one left I'm heading
over I'm heading over to that one Here Here You're raising
Okay Okay okay Got it That's a reload Yes Okay You got it
You got it You got it Oh Nice Oh my god That was so scary Oh
my god Thanks for the You res me I'm gonna send the love
Okay yeah Yeah I'm so low Okay Don't have gold res Wait
where's the Oh, I lied.
Oh, doggie.
Eve.
Eve, she's liar.
No, it's because he died in the lava.
I didn't realize he died in the lava.
Wait, you don't have gold?
No, I thought she had gold because I had to destroy her
armor.
Oh.
I lied.
I don't need you.
I will play Elstar.
Oh, you're gonna play Elstar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
okay oh i i got to kill with re 48 14 5.
oh you should you should run it okay yeah you should run it
that that means find me this find me this okay i'll find you
don't worry i believe okay there's nobody here right away
yeah we killed everybody okay yay all right we gotta go up
okay okay that's it nice wait they rest over here i saw it
all right let's go you want to go yeah yeah you can go do
you have jump tower oh no we can use this yeah i was like
yeah it's so it's so far wait wait okay wait okay i'll show
you guys what where i climbed come over here okay so like
i'm here so like i'm watching okay so like you know how we
were all here right here so you guys all climbed this right
you guys climbed this right
Okay.
That's how I felt.
Didn't I were already running away by the way when you were
talking?
Did you see, did you see though?
Yes.
You saw, you saw the slide.
There's one team.
Okay, I'm going over.
Let me check.
Wait, you're here?
We're here?
Hey, I don't know.
There's a...
Oh, I see, I see it.
Don't find me, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
I'm nice.
Hey, I knock one.
Okay, I'm pushing out.
In, in, in, on me.
Okay, I can't hear.
Where are you?
Oh, I cracked, cracked.
Last guy, last guy on me.
Okay.
I got one and knocked one.
Oh, he has gold.
I have gold now.
Go get him here.
Go die.
Oh, you got die.
Oh, so we shot.
Oh, I go die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay, I will go.
Die to the ring.
yeah yeah i'll show you guys i have i have it i'm like full
i'm like full right now yeah i have your drone yeah yeah we
slowly die oh my god this is zone one here here here some
names here here here
i flew like a rocket jump It would be funny if a team pushes
us.
What are you trying to do?
I have gold res!
Alright, nice.
Oh!
Yeah.
Wow.
There you go.
And then here's a drone.
Well, thank you.
There you go.
And I'll feed you some, she says too.
There's nobody here, by the way.
See?
I told you I have gold res.
Wow.
I told you guys.
Oh, gold is true.
Yeah, we're helping.
See, look at us.
Girl squad, girl squad.
I'm leaving.
You can't leave the girl squad.
Can I ask how many kills you guys have?
I have four.
I'm going to show you.
Okay, I have.
I've only been scanning people.
I have like 250 damage and 8.8 assists, by the way.
Oh my god.
A lot.
Wait, there's actually somebody here.
Oh there is where?
I don't know.
Let me scan.
Oh they rest there.
I saw it.
Yeah, let's go.
Let me just scan.
Yeah, let me find the lane.
It's time to give these boys some coolies.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
He's still low.
He's by himself.
How is he still low?
He's so low.
You know what, I'll scan them again for you.
I like assists.
No, he's one, nice.
Nice.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
They're all back up there.
Okay.
I'm just gonna burst him.
Atop.
Oh wait no no they're down here shouldn't.
Oh wait on me.
Oh god.
I need help I need help last guy last guy last guy last guy.
You're right here.
He wants to catch me.
He's fucking crazy.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
Look at this.
He actually got it.
What?
Oh my god.
My halve.
He actually let him kill me.
Another team.
Oh my god!
Wait, you got Resby back there?
I'm raising you right now.
I'm raising you right here.
Yeah, yeah, behind us.
Oh, you had a Resby kid?
Oh, nice.
I will go back.
I don't have a magazine.
I got grieved so hard.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's someone laying here.
Yeah, buddy, my stuff.
Yes, me.
That's me.
I forgot.
Wait, this one has a gold dock.
Yeah, I have gold.
I will give you gold here.
okay i need i need to grab my stuff guys take me back oh
yeah you can yeah yeah yeah they're raising over there yeah
they're raising anyway so i need to get my stuff there's
there's another team all here but um it's still here i think
you can you can grab your loot i need my loot back i can't
believe they're fighting here that's so up i can't wait i
got a magazine out someone yeah you scan somebody yeah i
scan i scan in there in there yeah i saw that too yeah we
can we We can...
Over there, over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
In front of me.
They're lying.
That's lifeline.
Oh.
Flesh, flesh, flesh, flesh, flesh.
Here.
You okay?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I knocked one.
Right here.
Right in front of me.
There are another one.
The other one's behind there.
Nice.
Where's the last guy?
I'm thirsty.
Yeah, fuck you, lifeline.
There can only be one lifeline in this lobby.
oh my god you're so selfish i'm not gonna finish this guy i
don't care about this guy but i'm gonna do this oh wait what
the fuck me hey they're fighting over here you want to join
i want to join okay what are you how oh she's over there
that's just health much to learn let me scan it out for you
okay here oh yeah yeah i see them i'm headed oh they did
they finished they finished yeah they're shooting your drone
now wait i'm gonna wait for ditto so she can okay the damage
for me okay oh no i'm not gonna tank damage what do you mean
you're the fragger you're the entry fragger i'm literally
support why support support can we attack at you you can be
an attacker too yeah but i'm literally support oh oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa let armor let armor crack
crack okay okay i'm batting i'm batting full squad there i i
You can go here.
I will queue up.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here.
I'm here.
Wait, I need like two of them.
Okay.
No, I can't.
I just hear you.
I will queue up.
It will queue up.
Yeah, we're heading over.
We're heading over.
I'm behind, okay?
I'm going to...
Yeah, I need a little bit.
Here, the lifeline.
We have to kill the lifeline.
We have to kill the lifeline right here in front of me.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Flash, flash.
Yeah, yeah.
Right here, right here.
On me too.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That's your team.
teams they're fighting they're fighting this guy's a solo
he's dead in that truck there's a oh yeah yeah yeah kill
kill kill this one kill this one okay okay let me let me go
scan them wait wait wait wait uh i want to okay okay okay
yeah i'm coming back they're down they're down there yeah
okay here there's nobody i'm pushing i'm pushing i'm pushing
i'm pushing right behind you they're down there they're
there okay oh there's there's someone here they have hit it
far Yeah, let's just loot.
Let's just loot.
Reset.
Okay, okay.
There's like a rat right here.
I saw him.
There, um, there's a lot of, um, team here.
There's another, uh...
I'll take the gold now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why are they?
Where did they go?
Okay.
I think, I think they win now.
Yeah, I think so too.
Oh, but we're gonna get camp out of the zone.
On me, on me, on me, on me.
On you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
On me, on me, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, right here, right here, right here, right
here, under, under, under.
Come here.
Oh, yeah.
He's, he's zipping, zipping, grapple, grapple.
On you guys.
Okay, I'm gonna, I'm gonna use my ult inside this.
Okay.
Wait, IVMP, IVMP?
Okay, okay.
All this poor fucking team.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I knock one.
Where's his teammates?
I don't know.
Wait.
You should die?
Maybe I'm here.
Flash, flash, flash, flash, flash right here!
Flash!
Oh my god, a plus fighter?
Oh my god, he's so low!
Nice!
Oh no!
Not nice!
He's literally one!
Here, I'll put a jump tower here.
Not nice!
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
I got him, I got him.
Nice.
Wait, he's here.
He's here.
Okay, I would go back.
I would go back.
Okay, I'm going.
You should come with me.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Okay, okay, follow me.
Follow me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming back now.
Oh, my God.
I'm so far.
I'm so far, guys.
Your support is so far.
100 on my ping.
Coming.
Oh, wait a minute.
I'm going to take this.
Guys, I'm looting.
I'm looting.
Okay.
They took the high ground.
We can go here.
Okay.
I think we can fight them if, um...
Wait, there's someone on our...
Wait, wait.
They're not here.
They're not there.
Where are they here?
Uh, they came here.
On my ping, on my ping.
Okay, okay, okay.
Lobo is cracked.
Okay, let me get him for you.
Watch, watch, watch.
Wait, what the f- I hate.
Big crack.
I got one.
I'm gonna...
flash flash flash whoa nice he's one he's one no there's
last guy last guy last guy no there's so much yeah i'm safe
i'm safe i'm safe i'm safe okay i i i i'm i'm really i hope
you're here okay okay i need energy armor i i got him i got
him don't worry there's energy here there's energy here okay
nice all right where's the where's the last two teams.
There's one over here.
Over here, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna get in for you.
Yeah, yeah.
There's two.
There's two over there.
Okay.
All right, I'm just gonna...
You know what?
Okay.
He's low?
Over there?
Yeah, I can't see him.
32, purple?
He's pushing you.
Are you pushing you?
I feel like there's someone near me.
Is there?
Like at the bottom?
Oh, I'm here, Mimir.
Yeah, one team, one team, not solo.
Not solo?
Okay.
I can see this guy.
I'm gonna, oh, I'm backing out.
I'm backing out.
I'm backing out to Hiro.
Okay, okay.
They are there.
Okay.
Yeah, we're, like, getting gatecapped.
Yeah, we have...
I have EMP, I have EMP.
Okay.
I'm gonna EMP them.
Whichever team we fight, the other team's gonna third-party
us.
I EMP, EMP.
Okay.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
One, one in.
Where is he?
All right.
Where's the guy?
Okay.
Wait, they're fighting?
They're fighting?
Yeah, but they're fighting a rat.
There's only one guy.
No, we should have let them fight.
It would have been funny.
You guys are rat versus rat.
Oh, that's really weird.
This is rat versus rat.
They're actually both one hit, I think.
That's the point, right?
I think you're about to die.
I almost got 4k.
Oh my god.
Another one!
I was just scanning.
Was that two in a row?
Energy comes easily cracked.
Yeah, Havoc is really good.
Look, I have 80, I think all...
You're an assist!
the assist queen oh my god actually crypto is strong yeah i
think crypto is strong in a team fight that's i feel yeah
yeah because then you you emp and then like did yeah because
dude they're trying to gatekeep us yeah and they just get
emped and they can't do anything oh my god we're so good
guys girl squad girl squad
that's it this is it how many wins do we get we got so many
wins yeah i i feel like yeah i mean oh i'm i'm silver yeah
you're almost yeah we all got you there from rookie to we
almost got you the gold i think i we can actually i can
actually go gold yeah i think so too i think ditto can get
to flat and then like yeah and then i great yeah yeah you
can get to gold the flat is crazy um how's your length now
i'm golds right now oh wow i'm flat i'm flat yeah i think
i'm pled no i think your plat no aren't you plat three i
think i am i mean silver three silver three My account is
only gold one.
Wait, really?
Yes, I don't pay any.
But you're about to get flat now.
All right.
Do we have anybody on this?
We have a squad here.
Yeah, we have a squad.
Okay.
Not with us, though.
It's like, hey, we can kill them.
If we die, we have heal.
Yeah.
If we die, we have hero.
Yeah, I'll immediately rescue right on them.
We land on their heads and punch them.
We don't need guns.
Oh my god.
Kooties, right?
Yeah, give them extra kooties.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, I have bad guns though.
I don't like my guns.
Where were they?
The ship?
No, they're at the big mod.
Big mod, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
so we're fine because they have to get big mod stuff finally
finally finally I can't remember how to pay a base
when she learned how to run she learned how to play true why
is car finder so heavy guys am I running am I running
Why does effects feel different?
I'm so slow!
I need energy, ammo.
I feel like, um...
Horizon is faster than Pathfinder when...
When running.
I think it's just the animation.
They purposely, like, make the animation...
Because, like, Gibby feels slow, but he's the same speed.
Yeah.
It's just they made his animation so slow that it looks
slow.
I see.
Oh wait, they're here.
They're right here.
Oh my god They're there with you Okay, where are they?
Here behind that rock behind the rock.
Okay What are my flash flash flash.
I'm pushing.
I'm getting oh, he's so low.
He's so low.
He's so low Oh my god.
He was so low.
Oh my god.
He's not low.
I'm gonna push.
I'm gonna push Uh, his teammates decide his teammates here.
Okay.
I'm getting this Okay.
Oh, nice.
Where did I get shot by?
Oh, you see?
I'm killed.
Yeah.
Their teammates are coming.
Okay.
I'm going with Ditto.
I cracked one of them.
I'm shield selling.
I'm not with you, Ditto.
You guys got close to me.
Okay, I'm coming, Ditto.
I'm taking one.
I'm not one.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm trying to see where they are.
Over here.
I said that solo.
Yeah.
And I'm still?
I almost knocked him?
1v3 Ditto, 1v3!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
On me?
Oh my god.
Hey, there's a lace, there's a lace.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Flesh.
On me.
Oh, here, here, here, there.
Nice!
Nice.
Oh, they have lifeline.
Yeah, they have lifeline.
Oh, they have purple.
Purple Spitfire.
Nice.
Spitfire, huh?
here yeah that's right they try to push us but they died a
dirty they shouldn't have shot at us we would have left them
alone if they didn't shoot us wait the cure package is right
next to us yeah oh yeah what's that it's a power there
because they don't want it you want it no already got two
last game i got two red guns so i'm willing to okay okay i
will use this all right nice oh i have my own package too
okay there's scope scope no i want a bag i don't have maybe
there's a bag in my package i have i have two scope oh
there's three bags here does anyone want them
I will get one.
All right, let's go.
How many do you have here?
Yeah, I have four.
Battery?
Yeah, how many bats?
Two.
I have two.
Oh, we grab one for her.
I'll grab it for her.
Okay.
I have an extra slot.
Wow.
I will get one.
I will get one for myself.
Okay, wow.
Wow, Ditto.
Ditto, you're really greedy.
I have four.
Yeah, but you could have...
Yeah, I have four.
For two!
I grabbed it for him!
Thank you.
Um, see, this is what separates me from Ditto.
I'm actually a good person.
I bought this for you.
No.
Really?
It's okay.
Don't worry.
If you want.
She deserves it.
No.
There's another bad way.
There wasn't a bad here.
I'm full now.
Alright, where do we go?
Well, thank Go-Keybird.
Um, Go-Keybird.
We have the...
It will help register.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, IGL.
Where should we go?
Okay, here, um...
There's no...
Wait, wait!
What?
Did you punch me?
No.
What happened?
I thought I thought there was an enemy.
Oh!
Wait, why?
Why did you think it was?
punch me you punch me no i didn't why i didn't punch you i
thought i thought i got shot nobody wait there's somebody
all the way there
yeah yeah did i immediately turned around
she freaked us like wait wait i heard a like uh i heard
something sound like a gun sound yeah yeah it's my lifeline
heirloom it's still air i see it's so noisy your heirloom is
so noisy
wait there's not here there is actually we're gonna eat no
lie no lie no lie i like how already i like how dinner was
like really over here oh my god he's so low oh my god what
did he what wait what one one guy with me what how how can
he get inside can you get in holy shit we're all so low oh
my god oh i'm gonna grab
That was so scary.
That's actually...
We could have all died from the maids right there.
I will kill them.
Okay, go!
Go, go, go!
Go, kill them!
Wait, shooting me!
I thought you were gonna kill him!
I kill one?
I'm bad.
I'm mad.
I'm madding.
Last one, nice one.
Lifeline ran, he ran, he ran.
He got started.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
them i don't think so so hey everyone oh we can go chase
them okay okay that poor guy okay i saw it i saw him i saw
him i see him i see him take on my side he's going right
yeah he's right here here here here here
Are you like you almost died?
You almost died.
It was worth it.
I got the shock stick melee.
That poor guy.
He's running from the cooties.
Got the cooties.
Wait!
I want some more energy armor.
I have to go back.
Okay.
I got gold res now.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, was there two teams?
It's always, every time.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm gaming.
Wasn't there like two teams?
I thought it was two teams.
No, there's one.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, only one.
There's nobody.
Oh, okay.
They were just super split up then.
Yeah, where is his body?
Where's Pathfinder this box?
Oh, here, here.
Oh my god, he crawls so far.
How did he get here?
Oh my god.
He crawls so far, little guy.
Yeah, she was trying to survive.
She was trying to survive.
Julia has a respawn beacon too.
Yeah, we need that.
I think that there's a squad there.
Yeah.
Okay, let me go check.
Yeah, a lot of squad in fragment.
Nobody here.
Let me check.
I'm going.
Yeah, I can hear them fighting.
There's somebody resing.
Okay.
And they're fighting, they're fighting here.
Okay, okay, okay.
You can go there.
What the?
Are you scared?
Really?
Yeah.
Oh, they're fighting.
The donkey is really scary.
Oh my god.
I, right?
The song.
So scary.
Oh my god.
I, right?
They have live lives.
It's so bad.
I think they already said.
I'll you.
Okay.
Yeah, we're coming.
We're almost there.
I'll crack it.
Go, Ditto, go!
Kill all of them!
1v3, 1v3!
I'm getting across, I'm getting across.
I'm on a cross.
Almost cracked Pathfinder.
I got one.
Oh my god, oh thank god, thank god.
On me, on me, left guy.
Okay, I got the bat, I got the bat.
Right here, right here, he's not low, but like he's by
himself.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
He is so easy.
I'm going to grab the car, but...
Wait, the other squad...
Like, there's another one just rest nearby.
They all rest nearby.
They all want to die.
They have to lose some stuff.
And me too.
Alright, let's see.
Does there need extra light?
Oh, there is.
Let me check.
Where's the last body?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, no!
Nobody...
Nobody has Barrel Stabilizer.
What do you want?
I see them.
They're all the way over there.
I made the... Okay, okay.
Let's go.
Okay.
They're all the way over there.
Hey, we jump there?
Yeah, yeah.
We just head over there.
Yay!
Oh, be careful!
They have devotion!
Oh yeah, they do, they do.
Careful.
They're like all the way over there.
Really?
No one there.
They're there.
They're up there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pretty far.
Yeah, I'm heading closer.
Yeah, they're far.
Blue armor.
Blue armor, blue armor.
Oh, their baby.
What?
Yeah, they're running their own.
Oh, wait.
They're only purple armor.
He has purple armor.
Yeah, one of them is blue armor.
The purple armor is almost K.
Okay.
Don't be careful.
I'm behind you.
Okay.
They missed it.
They missed it all.
Wait, the next team over there.
Okay, be careful, be careful.
Yeah, we might as well wait.
They're getting shot.
Yeah, they're getting shot by that team.
Oh, if...
Oh, that team's gonna get me, but...
I want that spot.
Team's gonna get it.
Wait, I almost have EMP there, though.
Oh, nice.
I almost have it.
Just give me a second.
Okay, I get EMP at him.
Wait, what?
It's pretty hard to push from here.
Yeah, because there's a team to our left right here.
Okay.
I was just looking at us.
It's okay.
Maybe we have to wait.
No, I want to see how I could save them.
Oh my god.
Okay, I know.
I know how to fight.
Kill that team first.
The left team or left team?
Left team?
Okay.
Kill that left team first.
Yeah, you pissed us off.
Yeah, oh that.
You made us angry.
Yeah, that's right.
I think the above squad is kind of...
Yeah, we can pull left.
There's still one team that's missing.
Where did that last thing go?
They keep hitting me.
Oh, here, here, here, another team.
Here, here, here.
It's all of me.
Okay.
130.
I don't know who it was, but...
Oh my god, Chulu!
Chulu, Bangalore, Bangalore passed my name.
Yeah.
Luba, I broke Luba.
Oh, they're over here.
One is up here.
Okay, I'll go with Ditto.
One is up here, by the way.
Bangalore is low, Chulu.
Yeah, I'm pushing up.
He's in here somewhere.
I think he ran ran Yeah, he ran Wait, yeah I'm pushing Okay
He got it I'm thirsty I'm thirsty Alright Pushing up This
team This team is so annoying I'm gonna EMP them Right now
Yeah, fuck Wait, they ran I'm gonna EMP them anyway Okay
Nice Nice EMP nice it's cool team yeah they're red red armor
that other team right here okay i'm gonna heal my help my
okay can you give me some doors yeah i can i'll come back
there they're like one minute they have a crypto too they're
cheating flying flying flying oh my yes they also have
better crypto we have better crypto wait do you see that to
our left yeah yeah ducky you got it on me on me they're
pushing they're pushing us I got it my god I got it no it's
okay yeah yeah that life I was like what when you did the
scan I was like I need to scan that what was he doing there
come on let's crack oh I don't have shield cells I'm gonna
grab some shield I got shield cells now okay do you have ult
your um I have 75 no oh life life line okay I have 10% oh
wait oh wait What?
What?
Don't worry, I'm clad.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the fuck?
No shooting.
Over here.
I cracked him.
Be careful left side.
There's one guy on the left.
This is two teams.
This is two and then this is three.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm packaged now.
I can get cover for us.
But we need a push up for this.
Oh, wait, wait, drop, you drop!
God, the other team is...
3.
Okay, I have EMP.
I'm crypto dropped!
I said okay.
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
Okay, I have EMP.
I'm gonna EMP now.
I'm selling, I'm selling, I'm selling.
Okay.
I have a bass here.
We need some.
Oh my god, I need that barrel signal.
Okay.
Oh, is that yours?
EMP it again?
Come on!
I'm going to Doki.
Yeah, I don't know where they are.
I'm going inside.
You know what?
I'm inside.
One here, one here.
one here yeah I think I'm I think I'm um I can I got There's
one there.
There's the dead.
Full dead.
Okay, you guys need to come in.
I got the heal.
Yeah, here, here.
Oh, thank you.
Nice.
All right.
Last one?
Last two.
Last two?
Yeah, it should be two because we killed the lifeline member
from that team.
Wait, I don't know.
Oh, okay, nice.
Yeah, we took that.
Let me go scan them.
Really?
Yeah, we have we have Crypto.
Let's just wait.
Oh yeah, we have Crypto.
Yeah, two, two.
Two.
Three.
Wait, wait, who the fuck?
Look, you faked him!
You faked him!
Oh, the lifeline was the team we killed earlier!
We just wait, wait, wait for them to push us?
Oh my god, I don't...
Wait, I want to queue up because they may have ash.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I will try to push.
I cracked them.
I cracked two.
Okay, I'm pushing, I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
I'll use make, I'm gonna queue up and tell my name.
First, uh, flash, flash, flash, flash.
He's here.
Oh, yeah, the flash!
Crack, crack, crack, crack!
Horizon.
Horizon won, Horizon won!
Last one, Horizon?
Yay!
For it again!
Another win!
Girl squad, cootie squad, cootie squad!
Cooties are too strong.
Nice one.
Nice, another win.
Oh my god, who can stop us?
Need like hand sanitizer.
No, another girl squad can only stop us.
Another girl squad.
Four in a row.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Four wins in a row.
We're so good.
We are so good.
Yeah.
wait diddo are you almost flat wait what rank are you yeah i
think maybe i'm gonna say go to go to we'll see here what
our rank is because we got four games goal three yeah
because we got four games in a we go on four times in a row
so like we must be close to plat for diddo now yeah yes yeah
those silvers never stood the chance yeah um it's also it's
gold now guys it's not just it's also gold now
actually oh my god gold one gold one like plan is already
like master players and friend yeah yeah this monster right
now we literally got we're getting it in like yeah there's
monsters right now it's not like No, Platt is masters right
now because it just the rank just started Yeah, I see that.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, yeah, we're now fighting masters too.
Yeah.
We're fighting masters now We were fighting masters.
We've always been fighting masters guys Oh, really?
Yeah, actually might have been by the way.
Yeah, I think so.
I think they sure Some of them had we had like a team of a
decent aim at one point.
Oh, yeah, yeah Like the Bangalore that sneaked up on Ditto
as well, that one was like...
Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Alright.
Don't scare the grenades.
Let's go.
I'm gonna loot the backhouses.
Okay.
No team!
No team, you some.
No team.
Yeah, there's no one on the contest on.
Yay!
They're scared.
They know we're here now.
Yeah.
They know our names.
Let's see.
I'm gonna go grab Oh my god I did a lot of damage Yeah you
did You're gonna try and get 20 kills Did you?
Yeah You were so close You got 16 Yeah I got 16 You could
have got a 20 bomb We were so close to a 20 bomb It was
almost there It was so fun Yeah Killing people is really
fine.
In-game, right?
In-game.
Yeah, in-game.
I mean in-game!
In-game!
Why are you talking?
Whoa!
Ditto!
Apex, in Apex.
You get Apex.
Yeah, sure, in Apex.
Yeah, because...
Except Apex, I can't kill anyone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can kill anyone and like you won't get in trouble.
all right let's oh yeah nemesis nice i'm gonna prowler it's
got um it's caught good car car's always been good it's
really good okay it's the better r9 r9 is really bad right
yeah yeah my oh yeah i need to i need to remove my pred uh
my pred t-chain on the r9 because i can't see Because I'm
not getting them.
Nobody's using it.
So there's no point.
I need to remove this.
I need to use, aren't I?
I need to put, um, like, another gun.
Oh, what?
Which gun?
I don't know.
Maybe Nemesis.
Because I use a Nemesis a lot.
Nemesis is so nice.
Yeah.
Nemesis has always been really nice, but Havoc is better.
Oh, yeah.
Lemesis is like- I'm gonna grab the Havoc actually.
We're on Havoc Nemesis.
Havoc Nemesis.
Yeah.
That's a lot of energy.
Our star is really good too.
Oh, thank you.
Our star.
Our star is alright for me.
I prefer Havoc if I see Havoc instead.
Elstar is nice.
Elstar is, but I don't know, like far Elstar is a bit shaky.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Oh yeah.
It's pretty hard to him.
I feel like they like remove the spawn rate for R9 too
because it's dog shit now.
I haven't found this.
I only found one art nine the entire time we're playing
There's no one used there Wait, there's actually there might
be somebody there by the way.
Oh, yeah, there's a disruptor here too, by the way Yeah,
yeah, I think I'm gonna go look Hey, I'm gonna I'm gonna
empty them.
Yeah, pretty close on my ping.
It's coming in here.
Okay, one guy on Coming to you.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
Here.
Can you get this guy?
Still.
He's home?
Oh.
He's fresh.
I'm pushing.
I couldn't get to him.
It's condo.
Yeah, he's too far for me.
No, he was too far.
Wait, she's running so far.
She's running like all the way there.
He's scared.
He's so scared.
Oh my god.
Oh, they use knife.
Oh, where are they?
They're so far.
On top, on top.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
They're...
Oh my God, they're already there?
Yeah, so far.
Let me you...
I'm gonna bring a package here.
Go do-do!
Get out!
I'm gonna loot!
Oh, now they know we're here.
They don't know you're here.
They're here.
Do you hear?
Because I'm looting here.
They are so run.
Wait, one is running.
One is running.
Where's the other team?
Okay.
Here's large guy.
Oh!
Okay.
I get this guy for you.
He's right here.
Hanq on Kondo.
That's pretty low.
I'm running.
I'm running so fast.
Dido, you keep running too.
Oh, dido.
He's okay.
I'm good.
Wait.
Doki, careful.
There's three.
Yeah, I know.
I'm here.
Careful.
I got shot by the longbow.
Okay, I'm waiting.
Should I go up now?
I think they're running.
I think they ran.
Yeah, no, they're gone.
Yeah, they're all gone.
I have a...
Okay.
Alright.
I'll be here.
While you guys jump, the tower.
I don't know where they're going.
I don't know where they went either.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
They snipe you there.
You snipe the building?
I don't know.
I got sniped.
Here, right here.
We're on ping.
Give me a second.
Okay.
All the way over there.
We're at ping.
Are they rotating?
Okay.
Why?
Oh, they're over there.
Run from me.
Look,
Pachi, be careful.
Wait, wait, yeah, this is another team.
They take the zip line.
What?
How do you have purple armor?
What the fuck?
Right here.
Maybe they take only...
Oh, that guy is...
Really?
Do you want to jump on him?
Fuck you.
All right, Ditto, Ditto, Ditto's rushing in.
Oh, that's a...
That's a rampart!
That's a rampart team!
Careful!
Careful, Ditto!
I'll be in here, here, here, here, here, here, here, here,
here, here, here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I can't look yet.
I'm going to shot a button.
I can.
Oh my god!
I couldn't hear.
Lampai is low.
Wait, there's like three people on my face.
That's why I was like, that's a Rampai team.
That's another team.
Yeah, yeah.
This guy's dog shit.
What the fuck?
Who threw that?
Wait, he's low?
Doki?
No, I can't.
I can't.
I'm getting long mode.
Wait, can you pick her up?
I can rise her.
Oh.
Yeah.
okay nice one oh my god i couldn't share the lamp height
okay guys i can't do anything about it i'm sorry you can go
you can go yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna craft i'm gonna craft
you oh my god yeah resin oh my gosh no it's okay we're gonna
craft me i told you that rampart team i could hear the
rampart team i felt it That Longbow guy was so bad though,
he missed like 100 shots on me.
And then he hit me the moment you need me to peek.
Okay, oh my god, the only crafter is like all the way back
here.
Wait, there's a Loba.
Wait, who's Loba all this at?
Oh, wait, wait.
I want to know if that player can team up with a silver
player.
No.
only gold wait actually i don't remember maybe diamond you
can't we'll see when you get plat we'll see okay almost gold
too anyway yeah i think like anyone knows no you can you can
i think i think you can can okay yeah yeah yeah oh they saw
people say yes it's three rank difference so you can oh
three okay then totally fine all right i just want to know
where the fuck that loba alt came Where did that team go?
Oh my god, where did that team come from?
Alright, it's my turn to be a hero.
It'll be funny if I crafted the wrong thing.
Shield battery.
I was like looking at it.
It's like reflex, you know?
You're so used to crafting shield that.
Thank you, Donkey.
Yay!
We're all alive.
Thank you.
This is your first, your first, your first, What's lame?
Wait, look at this.
There's a team.
Right here.
Which one?
Where?
Right here.
I'm jumping right now.
That's me.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
There's somebody behind us.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm backing up.
I'm going to be there.
I didn't lie.
I didn't like to...
Our loot?
No, I think we can.
Oh, it's so far.
It's the closest risk.
Wait, they're pushing.
are they i saw them run off i don't know where they're
pushing though ran they didn't push us no he i think he ran
here he is there he is he's behind me yeah they didn't
really push yeah what the fuck are they doing okay they're a
bit scared i'm not sure why wait wait um another team is
fighting um in the in the building what um maybe here okay i
need a little bit ammo what the fuck you're showing
everything at me oh what happened what happened what are
they doing yeah another team here another team here okay i'm
gonna do yeah yeah i'm going i'm going to you guys now i'm
like where are we have we have to go inside the ring we can
go in the car my chest like the one percent you only killed
99 of the bacteria
I will go up here I'm gonna go up here Wait, they're
fighting Hey, come here, come here, come here They don't
know, they don't know Yeah, you flanked them Hiro and I are
gonna show up here Here What did they do, doing?
I don't know, I got hit though They hit you They know we're
here now They know we're here I'm trying to get them back
Go, Ditto Where are they?
Oh my god, he's a low One guy low One guy low We're looking.
We're looking.
I hit.
I hit the purple armor, too.
Oh, my god.
I got hearts now.
I got arms now.
Oh, my god.
I got stuck.
Broke one.
I broke one, Doki.
I can't see.
It's so hard to see.
Bangalore is slow.
I can't.
They have it.
Oh, my need is.
My need is hitting.
Flesh, flesh, flesh, flesh.
They're in my third mate.
Oh, he killed me.
I'm in.
I'm hitting him.
Nice.
I'm pushing up.
Nice one?
Oh my god, he's so low.
Bangalore, Bangalore.
He's so low, yeah.
Don't you can't do it.
I'm pushing.
Oh my god, he's so low!
Are you down?
Yeah, yeah, he might come to you.
Just try and heal.
I don't know where.
Where did he go?
Nice one.
Down.
Where the fuck did...
Oh, he's over there.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
His teammates far as me.
Just refresh your armor.
Refresh your armor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll cover you.
I think I think that bangle ran away No, he was outside He
was outside the door I don't I don't have ammo Is there any
energy?
Yeah, yeah, there's energy in here There's a there's a
turbocharger in here Oh, I need that I'm gonna close this
door Oh, we gotta leave Yeah, we gotta leave Leave Holy shit
Yeah Maybe you can you can um Lay see me inside Yeah, yeah,
yeah Because it's a ring It's a ring tree Oh, yeah, we're in
free You have to run here Yeah, we have done.
It's okay.
Wait!
Wait, what?
Wait, are they lacing?
Yeah, they're lacing behind you.
Yeah.
No, no, that's another team.
That's another team.
Blue armor.
Right here.
Just one person.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
No!
I'm no camouflage.
Just run.
Run, run, push, run.
Wait, wait.
What are you doing?
Oh.
Here.
I need any, uh, I need anything.
Okay, nice guys.
Wait, do you have a Q?
Do you have a Q?
I do.
I do here.
I didn't know you had no meds.
I didn't know you were that poor.
I'll EMP them.
Wait, I don't have...
I literally don't have an I'm gonna...
Just craft ammo.
I'm crafting ammo too.
I'm crafting ammo as well.
Yeah, he's low.
Below us?
Um...
Like, they're below here.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, we gotta pray that this gives us...
Oh, we gotta go from below.
Yeah, yeah.
We got to pray that this gives us mobile res beacon.
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm leaving.
Wait, you're leaving?
I'm doing it for you.
Remember what I did?
Nothing.
No, no, no, no, no.
No mobile res beacon.
I'm gonna go to the beacon.
I'm gonna rest her at the beacon.
You're resting a beacon?
Oh, there's here.
Yeah, there's a beacon.
I'm gonna do it now.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh no, it's okay.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
No problem.
I'm worrying.
Oh, I'm worrying.
It's okay.
I think they're gonna push to you guys.
No, they are.
They are pushing.
Do you okay?
Oh, they push here.
Lobo!
Lobo's almost dead.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm trying my best to help.
Oh my god.
No!
It's not different.
I was running all around.
Wait, you can rest me, I think.
No, no, no, I cannot eat.
No, no, they're gone.
They're gone?
They're actually gone?
They weren't, yeah, they weren't here.
There's another team.
Oh, nice.
Wait, let me get behind that.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait!
That's my, that's my, that's my, that's my.
Nice.
Nice!
Look how you can't get his tie.
I'm trying, I'm trying so hard to live.
Oh Hiro, goodbye Hiro!
I'm up on top, on top.
Be careful, on top.
Wait, what?
Wait, what did he say?
Wait, I've EMP'd all of them.
Oh Hiro, there is no...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can literally craft.
What do you mean there?
I am not getting there.
You got this.
Holy shit.
The moment they walk up this, I'm dead.
It's the cake.
Oh, I hear the fucking lamp.
They don't know.
Is that it?
Yeah.
Yeah, they don't.
Yeah, lazy.
Yeah.
I can't, if I shoot, if I shoot, I die.
Oh my god.
They shoot?
Fucker, you actually...
Holy shit.
Are you dead?
Oh my god.
What the fuck.
Wait, maybe you shouldn't leave.
Maybe you should leave.
There's people to my left.
There's a rampart right here.
Oh my god, please.
I...
Oh my god.
Oh.
It's so hard.
re-deploying they're re-deploying yeah they have to fly they
have to they're scared they have to leave you alone leave me
alone leave me alone they died because only one hey two oh
they're they're slow they're full they're full they're full
there yeah you you can go to them later i think goodbye you
got this because the last one is lonely nine the last one i
that i think there's no cover
What?
Anyone inside?
Is there anyone inside?
No?
I don't know.
Can't even go inside.
This is so...
Oh my god.
Bro, stop!
You're crazy!
You're really crazy!
They're gonna lose.
Did they die?
No?
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Wait, how?
How did they let them do that?
I don't know.
It's so fucked up.
Well, it's because they're all the way up there.
What the fuck?
They're all the way up there.
They're crazy.
They didn't shoot each other.
Why was it a bloodhound?
That was the worst.
thing for us.
Wait, dude, this team is like dead, though.
No, I streak.
They killed and he eliminated us.
I can't believe it.
It's because Ditto died.
We didn't have Ditto.
That's why we didn't have Ditto died too early.
Oh my god.
Ditto, you were super IGL died.
What do we do?
What do we do when our IGL dies?
Yeah, we just can't do anything without Ditto.
I'm back, I'm back.
Yeah, I'm believe it.
They killed our strongest cootie.
You're almost flat though.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
I mean, I'm not.
How do you know?
Because you're gold one.
I just I just I just got to go on maybe Yeah, and two two
wins ago.
Yeah, so she should be close now Yeah, we got top three.
Yeah, we got top three there Yeah, I did like just a few few
points away or something.
Yeah, you should be Okay, we stop when we stop when Hero
gets gold and Ditto gets plat Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's
what we call it
Oh my gosh, guys how many wins have we that so far.
I feel like we won like every, almost every game.
The counter for that.
Like 80 games.
Like 80% of the games.
Team here.
Why?
Oh, there's a lot of people.
Oh yeah, that's a lot.
Yeah, why?
Why the win's that?
Wait, they're all going there.
They're all going there.
Holy shit.
That's not even where the good loot is.
That's the thing.
Wait, there's someone.
There's one right here.
One right here.
Okay.
Oh, apparently we had like five wins.
Oh, really?
Really?
That's pretty good.
Ooh.
A lot.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's the team?
You said there's a team here?
Yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
They're in the middle, the area.
Oh, the house?
Yeah.
This house in front of us?
Ghost squad is really strong.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Let's go, let's go.
Let's kill them.
Here.
Last time I played with RPA, it's so hard to get champion.
I know, right?
Yeah, you need all girl squad.
Wait, what?
Where did they go?
Yeah.
They...
They're here?
They killed somebody.
They killed...
Oh, what?
Over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to bottom.
Be careful, careful.
I got one.
Where's this?
Tommy?
Flash, flash, flash, flash, flash.
You got him.
Nice.
Oh my god, he has a PK.
He has a PK.
He has a massive, he has a massive, massive, massive,
massive for PK.
I don't know.
We're ready.
Massive, massive, massive, massive, massive.
Right here.
On the stairs, on the stairs.
They're not resting, he's not resting yet.
Yep.
Second floor?
Okay.
I can go, I can go.
He's resting, resting, resting, resting.
Oh, we're resting too.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I will go try close the door here.
We thirst at one though, we thirst at one.
Remember you can't touch me?
Be careful, be careful.
Nice, gui.
Nice, nice.
Come here, here, here, here, here.
Yeah.
Got him.
Yeah!
Girl squad!
Yeah, we're rinsing, we're rinsing, we're rinsing!
We're rinsing!
Okay, I need a healing... Oh no!
My drone!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm healing myself.
I don't have drone right now.
Alright, let's see.
I got... I got two shots.
I got two shots from Maas even.
Yeah, yeah, that massive fucked us up.
yeah i saw that i was like oh god you guys both went down
immediately yeah i like looked at him and i instantly died
and i was like okay i'm just like yeah that sounds right
okay emily i got mass you i'm ready to now it's your turn
all right let's go there should be a lot of teams in front
of us here yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna scan they're racing
they're racing oh okay you should come I have EMP.
I have EMP.
I'm gonna EMP them.
So fast.
Wee.
Wait, that's a golden longbow!
Where's that?
Wait, he's here.
I need it.
I want to run golden longbow.
Oh, they destroyed it before you could do it.
Too bad.
There's just one guy.
Yeah, I'm getting cross for you.
I'm almost there.
Yeah, I'm almost there too.
Or are they?
Over here.
Why is armor in the...
Oh my god, you got crossed.
You got crossed, yeah.
I see.
Oh my god!
I got so fast.
Okay, wait.
Um, okay, where?
Wait, I'm gonna, I'm gonna get, I'm gonna get there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll go.
Wait, they're chasing you.
Wait, they're chasing me?
Yeah.
Oh no, they know.
The blood helm.
They know I'm a lifeline.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
They know, grab her, grab her.
I'm gonna send them on a wild goose chase.
Did you get it?
No!
It's fine.
I'll just craft it.
Yeah, it's just crafted.
Might as well.
Okay, they're chasing me.
They're chasing me.
I just wanted to...
It's okay.
Yeah, there's two people on the death box.
Okay, so the bloodhound's just chasing me.
Yeah, it's just one guy.
You want a 1v1 bloodhound?
Oh, you can rest me here.
There's a person that climatized.
You want me to rest here?
Okay.
No, wait.
Team, I want to rest here.
People, people!
God!
Don't craft it!
Get them in here!
Go craft it!
No, you already crafted!
I crafted it earlier!
It's okay, it's okay.
You're already crafted!
Don't worry, I'll get your banner.
I'll get it.
Get my banner.
Oh my god.
I saw the scab, but I didn't know they would get to me so
fast.
They got to me so fast.
i really feel so sorry for you you think i can get it i
don't know what i believe i've been you think this is enough
the distance if you couldn't you can just cough at um so we
can yeah yeah let's see okay yeah let me try oh it's so i
might too far can you it's a far distance oh 30.
no is it Oh, oh, oh!
Yeah!
You know what?
Right here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
Yeah, I can grab my loot.
Nice.
Yeah.
Where are they?
I have no idea.
I'm not sure.
I didn't scan them all.
I didn't know either.
I got fucked up.
Where did I die?
Okay, here, here, here, here.
What?
How did they stay?
Oh my god!
They actually...
They can't get me.
another point from me you can't rest they stayed they
actually stayed oh my god ok they're gone they're gone
they're gone trust trust they're gone that's so fucked up
it's so fucked up oh my god hero they're gonna come for you
I'm running um like here
you're gonna get off the zip you're gonna get shot off the
zip i trust me they're gonna get shot off there's two squats
here okay i believe it's okay it's okay you just gotta run
to us because we let me see let me see oh
right behind you you know right behind you fight i didn't
find him we don't we do not we don't have anything you know
what do you mean we fight i even beat him it's okay there's
another team here there's a team right here there's a team
there's a night team okay god um guys yeah that was team um
it's okay there's a team right guys there's a team right in
front of me guys i have two Guys?
I think I'm gonna die to the zone.
Okay, I'm gonna risk this.
Syringe!
Oh no.
He don't live.
He don't just live.
He don't know.
I can't live.
You guys gotta live.
Live, live, live.
There's another team here.
Oh my god, they're in front of me.
They're in front of me too.
Oh my god.
Ditto, Ditto, you gotta live, Ditto, you gotta live, Ditto,
you gotta live, I don't, I don't help, I don't help, I mean,
you can come to my, my spot, Ditto, I have, I have, I have,
I have healed, I have healed, yeah, I'm trying, I'm trying,
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm going, just saw me,
just saw me, it's okay, it's okay, wait, I don't think, I
don't think Ditto can even resute, she's so low, oh no, it's
not, Oh my god, it's them!
Oh my god!
They have caught a spider!
They've chased us!
They've...
Oh my god, it's them again!
Holy shit!
Okay, we're just trolling, you know?
Yeah, yeah, guys.
We're not playing our best right now.
We were like...
You know, just rest here, rest here, right here.
You know, we...
No, we actually played smart.
not have rest there we were just trolling guys okay okay
guys if we wanted to try we won't troll this time we won't
troll each time we don't troll we're gonna we're gonna keep
winning again yeah yeah guys
See you winning all the time is like yeah winning all the
time is so boring.
We got to make it more challenging, you know, we got to make
it harder, you know
I don't know you you you jump where do we go um
No.
I will never decide.
Why you don't drop solo?
Oh god.
Wait, did a little...
Okay, okay.
When Ducky's solo, we just dropped somewhere with our...
Okay, here we go.
Okay, we got Lava Siphon.
Only Lava Siphon.
Let's go.
I loot bottom floor We have any teams of us.
There's a team Landing on us.
Maybe two.
Okay.
Yeah, see I saw them landing on us.
Wait.
They're actually on us.
Yeah, yeah.
On me
One here one here.
Oh, no I got one, I got one.
Oh my god.
I have we're two squads on my god.
I have I have nothing.
I have nothing Oh, no I just locked one here.
Okay, okay, okay, okay Okay, okay, okay, one guy here, one
guy here.
Okay, okay, I'm heading over, I'm heading over.
Oh shit, he he queued.
Oh, he put a key.
Wait, he's finishing.
Finish, finish!
Oh my god.
Okay, here, here, here.
Maybe you can tab us?
Yeah.
Oh, they're still here, they're still here, they're still
here.
Okay, they're still here.
Oh god.
Another squad.
Wait, there's another squad.
It's a game, you get it.
Oh god.
Yeah, it's good, it's game.
Oh god, diddo, diddo, diddo!
Where are you?
I'm sorry!
Where are you two here?
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Just done, just done.
There's so many people.
There's too many.
There's too many people.
I have no ammo.
Why did it land on us?
I couldn't even get a bladder.
Holy sh- Oh my god, they landed here too!
Oh no.
Let me go, um, the tree?
How about the tree?
You can- You can jump tower.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
Yeah, we're gonna let you jump down.
Oh my god!
Oh, I don't have ammo!
What the?
It's okay?
No, no, no.
We're still trolling, don't worry.
We're still trolling, guys.
We're still...
Oh, I made two teams fight each other.
Oh, wait, wait, everyone!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I started a fight.
Wait, look.
We are in the plat lobby.
Yeah, we're in the plat lobby, guys.
Look, okay.
Look, look.
Cheers.
Guys, we should try it now, guys.
We're in the plat lobby.
Wait, is it on plat already?
No, right?
No, no, no.
We're just in the...
She's just gold one, so we get moved to plat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We get moved to plat lobby.
Okay, now we know that the players are a lot better now.
We can't randomly play around anymore.
Positioning.
Oh my god.
I guess I'll play positioning.
Yeah.
I will play Pathfinder.
Wait, I thought you said Pathfinder is bad.
Why are you playing Pathfinder?
Pathfinder is good.
What are you doing?
Alright.
See, look, they're masters.
Wait, they have a bronze on their team too.
oh and um two default skins okay here we go oh we're landing
safe now too well hey how come now pathfinder is good after
you say pathfinder is garbage i i didn't say that i just i
don't say that he was low no you said he was big hitbox
didn't you say that it's okay i can i can play
know how to move i know yeah my memory is back okay yeah
yeah now you know you remember how to play fps games yeah
sudden memory loss yeah yes yes yes okay now i know it's
okay she learned after playing horizon she learned how to
play pathfinder that's how it works yeah here you go little
Wingman on Pathfinder is kind of scary.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, we saw her.
You scared everybody away.
Yeah, we saw you on the Wingman as Pathfinder.
It was really scary.
I say, I say.
But I'm looking at you as Wingman in this lobby.
You're not going to?
Okay.
Oh, I have it.
Like, everyone has a good M.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh, no!
You got blue!
What happened?
I got purple Ditto I saw blue Why did you say oh no?
Why did you say oh no?
Then why you said blue?
I got purple here Then why did you say it?
Then why did you say oh no?
Because I got purple Why were you sad about it?
She wants gold?
No, no, yeah I want gold I want gold Ditto's chat Can you
clip that gold?
You can clip that purple that she got?
No, healer.
Who do you trust?
Who do you believe?
I'm talking about your chat.
No, no.
I'm asking.
I'm asking healer.
God, I gotta go to the toilet.
Like, I gotta go back now.
No, healer.
I don't, I don't think he'll trust you.
Ditto.
I don't think she trusts you.
Oh, healer ignores.
Yeah, it's.
She doesn't trust you.
That's why.
She doesn't trust you too.
No, she trusts me.
She believes me when I said you didn't get purple.
She didn't say that.
Hiro.
You have to choose.
I have to choose.
Hiro.
If you don't choose, somebody in the world is going to die.
Yeah.
Wow.
You got to pick.
All right, guys.
Here's.
I forgot whoever this is the damage I'll trust you know the
pred keychain that I can never see because nobody ever runs
R9 anymore wait earlier that that that like octane why
didn't he play R99 oh she doesn't count that octane doesn't
count octane dock 10 the octane doesn't count all right I
rarely see it though honestly yeah I really see r9 oh wait
they didn't open this bin i i want to go to the dome to come
something all right okay and we have to evil our oh yeah we
need we need evil armor yeah yeah but here i give doki this
this thing oh do i need that yeah yeah i'll take it i'll
take it long okay i want to score yeah wait
or ch okay all right we'll find we'll see any scope any
scope okay i'll go find no one no one you know we're serious
when we start crafting we were not crafting early now we
actually have to craft you just randomly oh wait i have to
have that yeah you were supposed to grab the evil harvest
dude okay you were ahead of us yeah they're actually
fighting they're fighting here Oh, wait, we should go for
that.
Be careful.
They might be over two teams.
Okay.
I mean, we tell from Hiro's thing.
Yeah.
I'll check.
Why are they fighting?
They're fighting over in this town?
Yeah, over there.
Yeah, in the town.
I can, like, scout it out now, too.
I don't need anything here.
Are they high-fighting?
No.
I'm checking?
They are fighting.
They are fighting right now.
They're still fighting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, right here, right here.
They're fighting right in front of me.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going...
They're hard fighting now, they're hard fighting.
Okay, okay.
They're high ground?
Okay.
Can you put a zip?
Okay, okay, I'll use my zip line.
Okay, okay, then I will go get them now.
I'm gonna...
I'm climbing up on the stairs.
Uh, there's... They have one knock at least.
Yeah, they're listening, they're listening.
They have at least one knock.
Alright, down here, down here?
Shoot, he's down here.
Flash, flash, oh they're running, they're running, they're
running.
There's one down there.
Yeah, that guy's flesh, if you see it.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Here, here, here, here.
Inside?
They were flesh, yeah.
Down, yeah.
Two people, two people.
Inside here.
Okay.
I think they are running.
Are they ready?
Here, here, here, here, here.
Outside, outside.
There's one here.
Oh, one flesh, one flesh.
There's one over here?
There's one running.
They're all running.
Oh my god.
It's so scary.
Yeah, I'm with you, Ditto.
I'm with you.
If you lose that one, we want, I'm here.
Inside the building.
Okay.
I am heading to Ditto.
There's one over there.
There's one over here.
He's running to him, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, they're together.
Broke, bro, bro, bro.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm pushing up.
Nice.
Are there rising or no?
I finished one team.
Okay.
Right here, right here, right here.
He's running.
Okay.
They're using jump pad.
No, advantage.
Advantage.
I hear them.
Here, here, right here, right here, right here.
Yeah, right in front of me, right in front of me.
Oh my god.
He's not low.
Yeah, he's dead.
I got the bad.
Where's the last guy?
I don't know why he's running.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
He's running, he's running.
I'm gonna thirst him.
I'm thirsting him for loot.
Okay.
You don't have anything.
Oh, new team, new team, new team.
Behind us.
Okay, we have to... we have to go.
We have to push.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here, move her.
There's a new team right here.
A new team here.
Okay.
We have to go to zone anyway.
He's here, he's hiding here.
Hello.
We know you're here.
Oh my god, my aim's down.
I got him, I got him.
There's...
Wait.
Wait, wait, another one.
Yeah, wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait?
Wait?
Why?
Wait a minute.
There's one more?
We gotta go zone, I feel like.
Okay, okay.
How you going?
Yeah, I'm gonna go here and then take the zip.
Oh, nice.
And grab the Evo too.
Yeah, okay, okay, nice.
Yeah, we're like, wait a minute.
Why is...
They guys not dead?
Not dead?
Oh.
Where is it?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's okay.
Just go...
I'll go alone.
I'll go scan.
Oh, another team here.
Okay, we're here already.
You're by yourself, you're by yourself.
Oh my god, I'm trying to fly.
Oh no!
It's okay.
No!
We gotta run.
They're coming to us.
Only two.
You know, you know, you know, you know, you know.
We just want one right here.
We want another one here.
Only two and another one here.
Oh god.
Yeah!
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why?
You know, run.
You know, it's not smart to be here, you know.
I wanna run.
I really wanna run.
But like...
Wait.
What?
From chasing people to getting chased.
I don't know.
I'm safe.
No, you're not safe.
Wait, they...
Their ears or eyes are really good.
Yeah.
There's people on my box.
But I don't have anywhere else to go.
Wait, wait, you might be able to come back.
I'm so safe.
Wait, there's someone here.
You know, another team.
Oh, I'm not safe.
I'm not safe.
I lied.
They're right here.
I see the darkness.
Hiro.
Wait.
Wait, there's someone on my face.
Okay.
they don't know they don't know they don't have a bloodhound
there's no way they have a bloodhound what about me i'll get
you i'll get you i'll call closer i'll crawl closer i'm
crawling closer i'm gonna die to the lava ball crawl closer
maybe you can grab my banner yeah i'm gonna get it don't
worry i'm closer to you hira i'm close it's okay i'm coming
wait the so many shields out i'm outside the ring by the way
i'm outside the ring it don't worry i'm watching your heels
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay you're okay you're
okay it's only ring one or two yeah yeah yeah yeah it's ring
one it's ring one no don't worry don't worry you're just
gonna get closer you're getting closer wait it's ring two
it's a little bit painful wait oh you have You have to heal
this.
Yeah, you have to heal.
It's okay.
Oh, it'd be awkward.
You canceled your heal right now.
I'm dead.
I can't get that banner.
I don't know if you should do that right now.
I don't know if you should do it while you're in the ring.
I don't know.
That's smart.
I believe.
okay you grab you grab um turkey's banner and go to the tree
you have to grab it now there's 19 seconds left okay i got
it i got it here oh right here oh oh nine seconds oh i got
it i got it got it fast fast fast fast yeah be careful
another team res is over there you see that res is over
there yeah wait you can make it is your drone far enough for
that are we gonna are we gonna you're gonna die i have a we
won't i have a beacon yeah but at the moment you put that
beacon down everybody's gonna look at you how about how
about lunch i do anything do you think she's not gonna make
it there's no way there's someone underneath she's not gonna
make it yeah he doesn't see me no no no no sound that
there's a song there's people here here do you hear that oh
let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go let's oh we
should be able to climb it oh okay oh there's people here
though is there i think so is there it's none oh yeah one
team be careful i think they're inside the house be careful
be careful i think yeah i think they're inside the house
yeah yeah yeah why would it be like locked it's okay we can
we can how do you get back up how do you get back up how do
you how are you gonna get back up it's okay you know you're
stuck down there i'm gonna revive you have to go back you
have to go i don't think this is i don't think don't i don't
know hira i don't worry you're gonna come back up hira this
is round three this is round three i'm gonna revive i'm
gonna revive you guys are you above us in zone don't worry
like at uh 30 seconds i'll uh no 45 i'll put a respawn down
wait no then you guys you guys can land on top and I'll hide
my die.
You're the zone four.
You don't think that you don't...
Okay, I believe.
Put it down.
Do it.
I believe.
Guys, are they still there?
They're gone.
They left.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Maybe you can go...
Can you go back and come up here?
I'll try.
Okay, I'll try.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I don't believe.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to watch Hiro's HP go down.
Can you activate?
Can you activate the?
Oh, no.
No.
I think I'm...
Oh, my God.
I'm safe.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We have to go.
I'm here.
Guys, we have to go.
We have to go.
Oh, nice, Hiro, nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
The power of Ditto believing in you.
You live.
Oh, that creeper is gonna kill us.
Be careful, be careful, be careful.
I don't have heal room.
We have to kill this.
I'm gonna I'm gonna EMP them right now.
Okay.
There's also a team right here fighting too.
Wait, they're not here.
They went here.
They're slow here.
Take the loot.
There's an ultimate cell.
I have an ultimate cell for you.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god, this is ours now.
Wait, there's someone here.
There it was.
What a fun.
It's okay.
They went outside.
I don't feel okay.
The Pathfinder.
Wait, it hurts.
It hurts.
How do we...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
We're gonna stall again.
It's the past fighter!
Why did you all shoot?
Where is the pathfinder?
Oh, it's a past fighter.
Is he solo?
Where did he go?
Where did he come from?
Is he solo?
He didn't even see him at the bottom too.
I didn't see him.
I didn't see him either.
I was like, where did he go?
He just got...
Like, I cracked him and then he disappeared.
He literally disappeared.
Oh my god.
We can get...
We can get Ditto to Platt, I believe.
It's okay.
Wait, how much is it to Platt?
I don't know.
We have to leave the lobby to find out.
Really?
Oh my god.
find out the end journey we're not leaving oh yeah yeah yeah
did a rage quit so we can check really almost see my i can
see my point yeah did a rage quit so we can see it okay i
won't i won't die i won't die okay i may go how are we
saying okay all
right oh my god you know we're playing now we're actually
serious we're landing on real we're landing on for no
contest i'll leave the bottom okay how do you yeah i'm gonna
get to the center too oh a purple helmet nice gun nice gun
nice gun okay what is the center what do you have in the
center oh how did they die last time oh Oh, I got shot by
using a jump tower.
Yeah, you did.
You were the last...
There was, like, a full team that shot you down.
And we watched it happen.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
It was so sad.
I watched you die in front of me.
And then I died, too.
Well, I think...
Why did you die?
Because there was two teams.
Because the other team looked at me and I died.
There's a havoc here.
Do you want it?
No.
You don't want the havoc?
I'll take the havoc then.
How it is for the week.
Habits for the week?
I'll remember that.
If I see you ever use the havoc again.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm the week.
I'm weak.
There's two teams in Siphon.
If we want a third party.
Holy shit.
Look at Lodge site.
Wait, is there one person there?
What is that?
That's one person.
is in isn't it yeah there's one person yeah at staging a
staging staging yeah because no because their teammates at
their state teammate is at uh mirage okay that's why i will
i will go get um your harissa and scattering okay okay whoo
okay we have the pages on all right oh my god we're playing
zone guys yeah we're playing so on oh girl squad is trying
now all right where's the zone ditto okay i'm scanning i'm
gonna grab the health chest it's probably maybe kowtow no
this frag oh my god there is no one no all right guess we're
going to frag should go through the tunnel it's just yeah
yeah i think we Alright, I'm heading over.
Lifeline is heading over.
Wee.
Here I come.
I need a skill.
Oh my gosh.
Hurry up.
My car.
I'm Lifeline.
I don't have any mobility.
But Cape Doe.
Cape Doe doesn't have any ability to.
Well, actually he does.
when you level out like if his drone gets destroyed he moves
faster yeah see really lifeline has nothing yeah it actually
does there's a there's an upgrade where your drone time is
like faster and also you get like a speed boost Dino didn't
even believe you she was like really I can't believe him
this sounds like a lie oh you're are you trying to say are
you trying to say that Hiro will lie to you that's up no no
no no no i can't believe you would think that hira would lie
to you like that is this is this firester yeah your first
time knowing it huh yeah she doesn't play how did you know
that how did you know that because i level it out yeah yeah
you know how do you know i'm playing crypto It's not like
you played crypto for four hours now.
Oh my god, it's been four hours.
Yeah, it's been four hours.
Yeah, let's go to when you go to the frag.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I want carbine.
No, because I have carbine.
No carbine for you.
Okay, I wanna go grab that too.
All right.
Yeah, we gotta get that.
Okay, there is there is this squad.
Yeah.
Pick up here.
Okay, back.
Oh, I got one.
Oh, wait, no.
I should get that.
I should.
I can't take the heat shield.
Oh, okay.
I'll grab it then.
Here.
You're good.
Let's go.
Now we have to...
We have to think now.
We got to use our brains.
Okay.
We have to use our brains.
I'm going to be throwing my drone out constantly.
If we get a house, we can just chill.
Yeah, we have...
Yeah.
I think we should...
Um, which house?
Which house?
Which is a good house?
IGL, which house?
I pay for this.
This house?
Alright.
That house, that house.
This house, okay.
There's a lot of angles to take care of, though.
Oh, no, it's inside the link.
Oh, yeah, it's inside the link.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We could try this house, right?
Yeah, this house.
Yeah, I feel like this house is better than this house.
This house has too many angles.
Yeah.
That's how it's not good.
Wait, there's one team?
Oh, let's see if they're in this house.
They're really far.
They're scanning.
Oh, yeah, they scan this.
There's a bat here.
See if I remember how to climb this.
Okay, go this house.
Wait, did they change this?
They changed it.
Did they?
Yeah, you used to be able to climb this.
You still do it?
You can climb here, you know, Doki.
Like here.
Oh shit, there's no cost.
There's no cost.
Okay, I'm coming back.
The purple armor.
Alright, where are you?
It's raised.
Oh, over there.
I got the mint.
Let me check.
Behind the bin.
Yeah, I got spam here.
Not down there.
91, 91?
The catalyst is blue.
I'm checking.
Let me check.
Okay, there.
No, not your drone.
I'm trying.
Oh.
Oh, careful.
You come here.
I can give you a heal drone.
I don't.
They might come.
I think they're gonna push.
They're gonna push.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
No, they're not.
There you go.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Oh my god, they're flashed.
The bloodhound was so low.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, they're coming down here.
I'm sorry.
They're on me.
Okay, here, here, here.
Oh, careful, careful.
Yeah, it's fine.
I'm fine.
I have another grenade.
I almost have my drone bag.
I'm going to EMP them.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Blue, purple.
Down here, down here, down here.
Okay.
If you're EMP, I will go for this far.
They might push for that.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
How many seconds?
No, I don't think they're going to.
They're ported.
They're kidnapping.
Keep lapping, keep lapping.
E-E-M-Bing.
That is?
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
I have to drop!
I got one?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm battling, I'm battling.
I got one.
You're all batting?
I'm batting, I'm coming over.
Okay.
I dropped down, I dropped down.
They're resing?
Another team here, another team.
I'm hitting this one, Ditto!
Okay.
I'm going, going.
Down and down!
Oh, Bloodhound low, bloodhound low!
Another team!
Ducky!
me i have to go i have to go i will go oh i'm dead here i'm
dead then i'm going i'm going just run just run just run
just run just run yeah just run just run yeah just run just
run just run just run okay okay okay it's fine they they
also have one solo left yeah okay you can leave don't Yeah,
just leave, just leave, just leave.
Yeah, and craft us.
Let's let...
You got thirded.
That's what they get!
Why would...
I'm like, why would you fucking third us?
Why did they push?
Yeah, why did they push?
You stupid?
This is why you're gonna stay in gold forever.
Maybe they want...
This is why you'll never get back to Master...
Oh my god, one team here.
Oh.
There's no crafter here, too.
Is there?
You have to go all the way.
Yeah.
Why would they push us?
I don't know.
They're so stupid.
I believe in Ditto.
Oh my god.
Just go do it.
Oh, do it.
Where are they going?
Dude, they're on top.
Dude, dude, they're getting stuff.
Where are they?
Oh, they're getting shot at.
what what are they doing i'm so confused why are they why
are they here why are they out here gonna try and sneak away
yeah but now she needs to find a way to get crafter i don't
think there's there's unless like a crafter drops next to
her there's zero literally zero crafters holy Yeah.
Oh, what the heck?
What the fuck?
Okay.
How can they...
Oh!
Where did they come from?
They...
I feel like they were, um, fighting me.
Yeah!
What?
Where did they come from?
Wait, this is a duo.
Wait, there was a team here.
Oh, I got shot.
No, I got shot.
This isn't a team.
Yeah, this is another team.
Where did they come?
They were hiding.
They were ratting here this entire time.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, they were ratting.
Scary flat.
That stupid team that rushed us for no reason.
Yeah, they rushed us just to die.
Did they eliminate it?
Yeah, they died.
I'm pretty sure they got eliminated.
Yeah.
first pushers yeah yeah we got eliminated they're so stupid
they literally died uh just to kill us
yeah it's not stream snipers it's people being really stupid
in rank it was separates like good players with ungabunga
players oh the other team did bm though oh wait what uh what
bm yeah the other one that that killed us after yeah oh did
they yeah Yeah.
I didn't realize.
They just like insta-killed me.
Which team?
They didn't insta-kill me.
I was like, oh.
They didn't insta-kill you?
Oh, they insta-killed me.
All right.
One team, maybe.
One team?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, one team.
Where are they landing?
Okay.
I see a- We can go together.
I'm looting the bot.
Okay.
They might land on the left.
Okay, I'll go with Ditto.
Okay.
Oh, they went center.
They went center.
They're on me.
Okay.
Okay, it's light, it's light.
Oh, two teams, two teams, two teams, two teams.
I'm backing up, backing up, backing out.
I'm backing out.
There's two, there's two, there's two.
Oh, my God.
I like you.
Yeah, I'm backing out to loot more.
There's three.
There's three teams?
What the heck?
Why are you here?
This is shitty loot.
It's not even...
I think we go harvest there.
I don't know how I'm sorry.
I mean, I mean the last time.
I mean the last time.
Why G?
What the heck?
Yeah, what are they doing here?
What?
What do they want?
Yeah.
I think it was like one team, but then like it became
like...
Yeah, and then another team landed on the other side.
I'm like, this is not, there's not enough room for three.
That would keep you on me.
there's not even enough loot for this i'm okay here yeah if
if we we we won i mean we didn't have a light yeah we lived
that's all that matters we lived whoa whoa the server lagged
for me did laugh for you guys no no oh my god i have all the
signs right now oh they're supposed here oh it might might
be a bit laggy yeah i have all the signs it's coming I'm
coming here.
Alright, I'm coming over to you.
I'm gonna go back to here.
There's people in lava siphon, by the way.
Um, I saw like the middle was looted.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I saw it.
Weeeee.
Oh no, oh no!
Oh!
The server lag.
You just stopped moving.
I saw you were in place, so I knew I was lagging.
You got you got um package package loss.
I have everything right now.
Okay.
Oh, it disappeared.
It disappeared.
I think I'm okay.
I'm okay now.
Oh, he's looted here too.
Yeah.
I'm with hero.
He's looted here.
Okay.
I'll go to healer.
Maybe guys maybe we can we can loot guys.
We need it.
Let's get that evil harvester up the hill though.
I feel like.
Oh, I'll go get it.
Sure.
Yeah.
I can I can I can check it there.
anybody oh it's a lagging for me it's lagging it's lagging
okay i'm not crazy then that's good to know oh there's a
team that just flew where do they fly to i don't know they
flew like here
all right wait that's that's really dangerous wait i'm with
you yeah yeah i'm looking for you i'm We're gonna loot this.
Yeah, we need that evil.
We need that blue armor.
We can go here, I think.
We can go here.
Can you scan here?
Okay, okay.
Scan the beacon.
Yeah, yeah, that's a good idea.
I think we can loot here.
Yeah, we can.
I'm pretty sure nobody looted this.
Be careful, be careful.
That might be another team come from...
No, yeah.
Yeah, it could be.
It's not looted.
I'm looking at it now.
Yeah, it's not looted yet.
Yeah, they jump from that place.
I'm gonna... I'm putting my...
Wait, there's one guy!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Be careful, be careful here too.
His team is there.
His team, his team is there.
On the tunnel?
Two, two people.
Oh, there's a blade!
One team, one there and two in the tunnel.
Yeah, where's his team then?
I think it's... No, it's still... Yeah.
No, should we...
No, there's three there, I think.
I think maybe they're super close.
I think they'll head to us, right?
Or they can go around.
They might go around, since you scanned them all.
We could just go...
We can just go ahead to zone now.
Okay.
Yeah, because there's too many teams behind.
There's 16 teams still.
I have two.
I have three.
I have zero.
I have three bats.
I can give Hiro one.
Okay.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Yay!
yeah okay okay that there's one team in monomain um they
might scan the ring after yeah so yeah we need a scan ring
too yes i'm gonna scan the ring no oh yeah i know can if she
no wait i can't scan people oh no no only people yeah yeah
people only people okay before he before he could yeah yeah
before you could even know you can't okay oh yeah one team
that one team that i think they they wait for the ring okay
you know i got you more bad wait wait for them scan the ring
first and we scan thank you okay then i'll go here me too i
want to see if there's a scope if if we fight we will get
through it by um the party yeah i think so too i think so
too we gotta be careful yeah Oh my god.
We are so careful now.
Did I scan the ring?
No?
I'm not scanning.
Oh, I think they scanned the ring.
They scanned earlier.
They're rotating.
Not yet?
One.
One squad.
So I'm still here.
They're rotating.
I think I...
No, there's one squad here.
Here.
Oh, okay.
There's two squads now.
Okay.
Two squads.
All right.
Ooh.
Can I scan?
Yeah.
Just...
Let me check this game.
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
This team did not come here.
They did win there.
I was scanning.
No, there's another team right here.
Okay.
Alright, there's there.
I'm gonna head to Ditto then.
I'm heading to Ditto.
Okay.
They went to the tunnel.
Maybe we can go pull right.
Alright.
We can go from the right, maybe.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I need a scope too far of my carbine.
If anybody sees one.
I am running at zero scopes.
I have one and two.
One and two X.
Do I need it?
No, I don't want that.
I need a...
I need a 2 or 3 X.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll find one.
I believe...
I believe in us.
Okay, why are we still here?
Why are they still here?
okay where are they yeah where are they why are you guys
here leave leave we're trying to gain SR I have evac tower
okay I'm heading over all right all right I'm heading over.
I'm almost there.
Oh, somebody has a PK.
A golden PK.
They're flying.
They're fighting up.
Okay.
We can run.
Yeah, we'll follow them.
Wait, no, they're fighting, yeah.
Right over there.
So we should go.
I won't take that.
Yeah, okay.
We go here.
Okay.
They're fighting right here.
Yeah, yeah, we'll fight.
We'll fly over them.
Oh, they're lasing.
They are lasing.
Okay.
Yeah, well, we go.
Yeah, we go.
We take over there, over there.
I don't have a scope for this, so yeah.
Take that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We shoot them from the backs.
Here's one guy here.
Yeah, shoot them the backs.
I can.
I'll go with Ditto.
Yeah, I'm in with Ditto, too.
I caught Mirage.
I'm looking.
Let me scan.
Over there.
I got Mirage.
I...
Wait, I didn't get Mirage.
I got somebody else.
Wait, here, here, here, here.
Right here, okay.
Here.
I'm a second thirst.
I will go right.
I got scope.
Wait, three.
Three.
Where's the guy?
One on me.
Oh, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading over to you.
Nice.
Pushing, pushing, pushing.
Another guy.
They're pushing, they're pushing you down.
They're pushing you.
Okay.
I'm battling, I'm battling.
Pushing, pushing.
They- they Cossack altered us.
They're lacing.
Come back to us.
Come back to us again.
Okay, I'll go back.
I'll go back.
Another team- Another team is shooting us.
We have to back up.
Okay, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Yeah, yeah, there's too many teams shooting us.
They have new castle.
Yeah.
They have Cossack too.
Okay.
Oh, that's a window.
There's a guy right there.
There's a guy right here shooting us too.
Wait, two my left- Come on up.
They're flying over us.
It's okay.
Yeah, this team's still here.
I'm giving us cover That's why they didn't make it Oh
Batting I'm batting I'm here.
There's heal drone on me Go careful ditto Okay I'm cracking
him.
I can't see.
Oh my god Okay, I got us a lot of bats I'm gonna eat a alt
XL.
Oh, I have only one side.
Alright.
I get almost EMP.
They're running to the left.
There's a team to our left as well, careful.
I'm picking them.
I think they will get shot.
If they got shot from the left side.
I'm gonna get across.
I'm getting across right now.
They ran, they ran, they rotated.
I saw them rotated.
They're...
This team is also...
uh redeploy i gotta get ammo i have no ammo i'm gonna get
here what ammo all right i'll get i'm watching them fly i
want to know where they're going let's do that there's a rat
right wait that's another team there's a rat team here make
sure they don't fly to us yeah they run this way they're
called this way yeah we can keep here we can keep here oh
they're still here they're still here okay i don't see them
i don't see them i don't have angle.
No angle, no angle.
Okay, okay.
What kind of ammo do you need, Hiro?
No, I'm coming back.
I need the light.
I have no light.
Okay.
It's fine.
We have to take this spot.
Okay, I have my alt.
There's a team to our right here, though.
That's the thing.
They went there.
I'm going across.
I'm getting across here.
They're still there.
They're still here.
Wait, down?
Nice.
They have new castle.
Oh, we can do that.
Nice, nice, nice.
Be careful here.
Okay.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
Actually cracked.
Okay.
Make sure there's no rats.
I do need, I do need.
What ammo do you need?
What ammo?
Yeah, I don't have it.
I can give you 20 more.
Okay, thank you.
Where?
Okay.
Is there anybody on this box?
No, no.
That's why I wanted to go try and loot it.
That's right.
Can you use you don't?
Yes.
If there is one people we can go.
Oh wait, here, here, here, here.
Right here, right here, right here.
They're here, they're here.
Here, here, here, here.
Wait, you should go loot that box for like ammo for Hiro.
Just loot it for me.
No, no, you loot all the ammo for us and then you come back
to us.
Because like Hiro can't... Hiro's more dangerous to go.
Yeah, this guy is shooting the bowl.
Bottom guy.
Okay, they have a lot.
They have a lot of light ammo.
Yeah, grab a lot of light ammo to us.
Yeah, I need some too.
Yeah, grab as much as you can.
Okay, a lot.
I think EMP, EMP any spot here.
And here.
Where?
You're here.
Here, here, here, here, here.
I dropped a grab some too.
Okay, okay.
What else is in there?
I will go back to it.
We have to go to a point.
We have to go to find a place to, uh, Stay at I haven't
redeployed want to read up where do we go where do we go?
We need to figure out a place to go?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, let me check let me check.
Let me check there's a guy.
Okay, okay You know what?
I'll get it.
I will take I will take I will take the top Yeah, I'll hear
they're all here.
They're all here.
It's all here I'm getting closer.
I'm getting closer Careful.
I'm coming over.
I'm here.
Okay.
I knocked you.
Only one.
I can't.
People below us.
He's down here.
I'm batting.
I can't do anything about it.
Where is he?
Right below us.
Hiro needs a zip if you have one.
Where is he?
Oh, loot for this.
Loot.
You need loot.
Okay.
I'm gonna see if that has new two.
This is...
Okay, I need some loot here.
Okay.
We can go back out.
Yeah, I can't go back out.
We need you to get us a zip to come back up.
Oh, I don't have a zip.
Okay, so we need to figure out how to get back up then.
Wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
5.50.
We can...
This is not...
We can stay here.
This is in zone.
Oh, wait, wait.
Wait, what?
He's Drake, broken.
I can't get to you.
Oh, I can.
Okay, come over.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We can come up.
We can climb up here.
Guys, guys, guys.
Okay.
I'm figuring out how to do this climb.
I just did it.
Okay.
Here you go.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Oh, here, here.
You climb this.
This way, let's go.
Okay.
Give it.
Oh, okay.
I do.
I don't think we need it.
We're in zone here.
We have to take hide off.
Yeah, but this is zone.
This is zone.
Be careful here.
Yeah, yeah, you can come here, Doki.
To our right, to our right.
It's safe on me too.
I'm giving us cover here.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me check.
They're in the They're in the truck.
And then this one's over here.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna look at them from the side here.
There's one behind there.
Okay.
I will stay on tall.
I cracked the guys over there.
Oh my gosh, what the fuck?
Okay, they did not like me.
They broke my door.
I almost have EMP.
Whoa.
Wait, they're charging you?
Push me Try to get Guys, I need help They're full pushing
They're full pushing What the One hit One hit One hit One
hit Lifeline He's slow He's slow Nice Nice Last guy Last guy
What the fuck Is wrong with them Swap Swap Armor What's
wrong with them Yeah Why did they push me Oh What They did
not They really mad that i did that they were fighting i
need to i need to take the hiding off yeah yeah they're
fighting i need i need to grab blue they're fighting they're
fighting they're fighting because we were there too coming
over i'm coming over here are all broke i'm pushing up
pushing up over there i'm pushing up too
let's flash one one okay i got one resin resin yeah here you
should be able to get
I'm pushing.
I don't know if they're flesh yet.
That's nice.
I'm batting.
Be careful here.
All right.
I'm climbing.
Wait here.
Where are they?
To my left.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hey, here.
69.
Nice.
Over here.
Broke.
I'm here nice last team nice oh yes oh yeah we played
seriously guys we can win when we're serious okay we can win
when we're fucking around and we can win when we're serious
holy shit what the fuck was that team that rushed me that's
I was like I was like I was kind of I think I think what I
think they they thought that they were solo I think so too I
think they thought I was solo I was like yeah so they pushed
yeah yeah they like I was I like cracked one of them and
then he did not like that they were so mad I think you're
angry it was so mad I was like what did I do I just I'm just
playing support
Yeah, I was like, I was like scanning around.
I was like, wait a minute.
They're all there.
Yeah, I cracked one and then they pushed me.
I was like, guys, why didn't you push me?
Yeah, they pushed in and died.
Yeah, that's so fucked up.
Guys, never push a solo lifeline because she's never solo.
She's not solo.
She's never.
Life can get craft better, so, yeah.
It's like, never assumed.
That's so messed up Did it was sure to be like almost flat
You're still gold one?
Where are you flat?
I'm actually really surprised Yeah, you're still gold one.
I thought that was their plat game Me too.
Like we got a lot of points there.
And we got a lot of points and we got like, uh, we got first
here all right ditto oh no i feel like hero's gonna get gold
before she gets plat why why i i think if i go on again i
think i i might get plat all right here we go okay we go sky
hook all right oh no calm down calm down ditto got little
robotic one team one team i'll have a master's trail i see
that you don't speak coming okay i will go right there go
right Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going on the other side here.
Yeah, I'm going in.
They go left.
Okay, I got carbon.
I got, um, all data and, um, yeah, I have all data and, and
sentinel.
There should be here.
Wait, uh, L-Star here.
Hey, they go?
They go here.
Yeah, I see them.
I see them.
They're here.
They walked across so i'm behind them they're running
they're running to you guys i'm right behind them one one
guy i'm always i have to i have i have to pull back okay
yeah she they're they're looking at you okay broke one i
will go back i will go back yeah i'm right behind them i'm
right behind them i can push them whenever you guys are
ready they're going to they're gonna push they're pushing
they're pushing they're pushing they're pushing i see them
pushing one is still there though yeah they're pushing I got
the bat okay shoot my drone be careful on me on me on me
they're looking at me they're looking at me now yeah they're
looking at me they're all looking at me I need you guys to
help no he's flesh oh my god I can't I can push oh they both
looked at me oh I'm rolling okay I can't push because
there's one way I can't wait I can't diddle yeah I think you
guys should just follow back follow back I didn't realize
they both are gonna turn around and look at me.
Okay.
That was my bad.
Only one guy pushed up to you guys.
The other two were, like, on me.
Yeah, because there were one guy looking at us.
Yeah.
How dare they?
I need to remember I'm lifeline.
I can't flank.
Lifeline can't flank.
to invade me i think i can actually craft her should i craft
her yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah do it do it
is fighting here they won't know okay they won't know you
can res me right here and then we can third party this team
here oh you're afraid okay i i will try to get you guys all
right we're resing i'm too squishy to play A little squishy
lifeline.
I actually don't know where they're fighting.
Where did you see the fight?
I'm not sure, actually.
I heard them fighting, but like, it ended.
There's one team going to a guy.
Oh.
There might be a lot of teams over there.
In Skyhook.
I have no idea where the team is, though.
I'm looking around.
Yeah.
Oh, they...
They're fighting at the Bloodhound.
Oh, they're fighting there, so they're safe.
Yeah, Bloodhound.
Is this place safe then?
Yeah, it's safe.
Okay, I'm going to go to the middle then.
Oh.
I know one.
Nice.
Where did you knock them?
You can do it.
Ditto, where did you knock them?
I think she's like...
Oh, okay, we can go to her.
Let's just go to her.
Okay.
I'm heading over now.
I'm sliding.
Yeah.
Well, I'm going to grab the evil harvester for us.
Oh, never mind.
We don't need it.
Wait.
That's a bit dangerous.
Diddle your nose.
middle okay i i will go back i will go back okay okay yeah
we're here though yeah they're over here they're over here i
see them okay one's in it one's in this house one is in this
house okay i think we'll we'll get squished i i think we can
we can go there alone yeah yeah i scanned out somebody
they're there yeah yeah that i saw that guy here oh They
bloodhound ulted me.
I'm gonna try and even...
Pull back, pull back, pull back.
I'm falling, I'm falling, falling.
Back, I'm falling back.
I'm okay.
They have a blue armor.
Yeah, I'm okay.
Oh my god, that's a gold longbow!
Guys, I'm gonna get that.
Okay.
Guys, I need that, guys.
Guys, you don't understand.
Do any baddie?
I'd have five bats.
Yeah, I do.
I don't have bats.
Guys, I haven't...
I've been trying to get a gold longbow for so long.
Okay, I'll give you two here.
Really?
Yeah.
When that moment when I got that when I got that first gold
Lombo and then I got died because of flank It made me so sad
It might They might come to us Okay, they passed by the
team.
Biddo and I are really far.
Yeah, they come to us.
This come to us We're far.
Do you want us to come here?
Wait, there's one here?
Yeah, there's someone in the tunnel.
There's someone in the tunnel.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I'm heading back.
I'm going up the house Oh, shit.
You have one almost kept one every time Ditto, Ditto,
someone behind.
Yeah, Ditto, we need help, we need help, Ditto.
Okay, okay, here, here, here.
I'm like stuck here too.
I'm gonna, let's get one, I kept one.
He's one behind this car.
The car, yeah, who is...
It's all on top.
We have to go to Doki Place.
Yeah, come here.
Yeah, come to me, come to me, come to me.
The blurb on D.
Wait, I need help.
I need help.
Yeah, yeah, I'm trying to cover.
Oh, I can't.
I can't cover.
I can't.
Dude, just two teams.
Wait, wait, wait.
You can actually get me, I think.
Okay, dude.
You're fighting.
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
Uh...
Oh, yeah, okay.
Okay, you're okay, you go this.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh my god.
You have a queue?
Yeah, dude, come here, come here.
Come inside, come inside.
Wait, wait, there's a bit of grenade.
Okay.
Can I push us?
Come inside?
I'm pushing and the queues out here.
We can't go.
We can't go through it.
They're fighting.
Yeah, wait I got one.
I got another.
I got it.
I'm just gonna snipe here I'm just gonna snipe because I
have gold.
Okay Yeah, I'm a ditto.
I'm a ditto.
Okay, I got about I got about two team.
Yeah, I'm covering.
Yeah, I'm just I'm just sniping from outside I don't know
possibly below us.
I have no idea where they are.
I knocked two They're lacing.
They're lacing.
Yeah, I think they're playing inside now.
They're playing inside.
Oh no!
He's not alone.
Okay, I'm gonna try to come here.
No, no, no, no.
I can't come inside.
There's a...
Oh my gosh.
I couldn't come inside because they...
I think you're gonna have them.
Two, two, two.
They have two.
Yeah, there's two.
It's fine.
I can craft you here too.
Okay, you can carve us later.
Goodbye.
Oh my god, that Hargok!
That Hargok is really great.
Yeah.
Did you say it was trash?
You said it was trash!
No, no, no!
If you're- Wait, this guy hit all his shot on me though on
the Hargok movie.
Oh, that's scary.
Oh, that's scary, yeah.
Yeah, he did 188 Hargok hit shot, by the way.
Yeah, I think he could be a cheater.
Yes.
I'm a bit scared of that one.
Yeah, I'm gonna leave now.
I'm gonna I couldn't come inside the the catalyst uh locked
the doors So I couldn't go in I was like no I'm so far away.
Oh, yeah, you can you can uh be careful be careful right
side.
You can Leave us here.
Yeah.
Oh, I see that.
Did you guys see that there's Yeah, I see that.
Oh, oh, they're fine.
They're flying away.
Oh, not yet
It's okay.
There's no one.
There's no one That was That's the one No no Don't get Oh my
god It's really It's really close That's Oh my god Oh
they're fighting Different team Okay No I think he was
trying to shoot me I think he was trying to No no I think I
think he was fighting A different team No I'm just gonna
rest you here I'm gonna rest you here We're ready Okay I'm
still It's still Um Ruin two Yeah I can't believe It's not
okay Lie to us again There's no Nobody did.
I didn't see anyone.
Really?
Oh, okay.
There's no one there.
Lily, Lily, I didn't see anyone.
That was the scariest fucking...
I literally had to walk to the left.
She did it to me before.
I didn't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I would never.
I am.
I, yeah.
I don't know what you were talking about.
I'm a Team player.
I would never.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I would never gaslit my teammates.
You're lying.
No, I would never.
Why would I lie?
I'm just gonna die.
Okay.
I have gold rest.
I have gold res shield.
Just come to me.
But like.
Okay.
Yeah, I have gold reshield.
Okay, you laced me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're going to craft?
Laced me?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, why the fuck are you guys?
Guys, I don't have a lot of hills either!
Okay, they're not decamping us though.
Damn it!
We have to go to in, um, tunnel.
Going...
tunnel okay okay i have two two syringes left okay okay it's
okay you guys go i'll i'll try and go separate okay and see
if they i'm also gonna craft a med kit okay oh god oh god
they're shooting me so it's okay oh my i think i might die
please you're so far ditto i can't pick you up there it's
okay i'm safe okay if i will like it i will survive you have
to come here oh no i'm not lucky i'm not lucky why why why
where did you go where did you go okay oh i will come to you
i will go to you come to me come to me come to me kido's
alive too i'm alive i'm going what the heck there's no sign
in here
Hello.
You have to come to me if you want heals.
There's no heal.
You have to come to me.
There's heals right here.
I'm trying.
You have to come to me.
Oh, I'm leaving.
Okay, we go, we go, we go, we go.
I think we're gonna die, Hiro.
I think I'm gonna die.
There's people right in front of me.
There's no other place to go.
We have to fight.
I will go on top.
I will go top.
There's three squads here.
Bang a little monster tank.
Be the one.
I got bang.
But almost tank.
Oh, guy.
Oh, please.
No!
You're gonna die!
God, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
There's a prison here.
You have to live.
Ditto.
Quiet.
Just quiet.
Wait, they're resting in front of you.
They're resting in front of you.
There's so many people.
They're resting right there.
Oh, I hear them.
They're resting literally right in front of you.
Literally right in front of you.
I got scared.
They're gonna shoot you in the zone.
the sound did oh yeah scan can i can i heal no i don't think
you should just heal you might as well no i go scan holy
shit bro and then there's so many people there's so many
people hey guys i got plus 55.
no i got plus 17 i was look at the wrong person wait what
you could look at your RP and the ranked oh yeah yeah we
could more at least I got to use my long bow guys I got to
use you yay I used the long bow I'm so happy holy shit who
would have thought who would There's so many squads there.
It's like impossible.
There were so many people.
And we had no heels.
We were broke.
We were poor.
I had no heels.
Yeah, I had no heels.
And they have blood.
We were so poor.
We were crying.
Please, can someone donate have heels to us I wish you know
like those games where you can get like chat to help you and
stuff like those like Twitch plays like they do like Twitch
plays something and then they like send you stuff while
you're playing like the Hunger Games the tributes I wish we
can get tributes oh yeah like sponsors yeah yeah we play and
the chat sends help kids to us like sends us tributes and
sponsors imagine you sponsor like a craver yeah that should
be a thing there should be into chat integration in apex
that would make the game more alive one team one team one
team okay i'm gonna land here in the circle okay i'll go
with ditto here i wish which kid i wish chat can sponsor so
we can get one team one team i see them they're right over
here okay okay see oh my god there's a triple take i'll grab
the triple take okay oh my god are you here they're here
they're there is there any weapon i need like oh my god my
god there is my guy is like oh my god my gun's talking
there's a lot of guns here okay okay i gotta okay i gotta
pay the gun there's alternators there's everything down here
yeah i need a weapon
Okay, I'm ready to fight.
Where are they?
Oh, I'm sure where they are.
I'm waiting for the scan before I push up.
Okay, I'm waiting for the scan to...
I'm not sure.
Oh, they have a crypto, too.
They have a crypto.
Are they scanning your drone?
Oh, I see them.
Oh, they're running too.
I picked them.
I grabbed them crypto over there.
Behind the container.
Okay, I'm pushing up.
They're like right here.
Wait, they also have a sniper.
But they're better at it than me.
I think they have a scope.
You on the tower?
It's right on the tower.
I'll scan them.
Let me check.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, Crypto's like here.
Alright, I'm pushing up then.
Wait, yeah, the Crypto's close.
He's here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they scanned me.
They know I'm here now.
here here here oh no hi okay on okay you got it i'm pushing
up i'm selling i'm selling okay i'm telling oh he has a
massive oh i might be dead oh that's right okay go go go
okay this side is okay i'm here i'm not even i'm playing
from na She's almost dead.
Yeah.
I will go kill her.
Down here, down here, crypto is here.
Crypto is here.
Okay, I will go kill it.
Where is it?
Oh, there, where there.
I see him.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Dead, dead, dead, dead.
Nice.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
I don't know who you are.
You are so toxic.
Yeah, this is our POI.
Leave our POI.
What did it do to you?
They shot me.
They shot me, okay?
Yeah, that's right.
I'm going to do this to you too.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
There's a fragment.
Wait, we're still free here.
Yeah, we're still free.
We can loot.
We should go to No Name and loot a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're broke.
She's crazy.
Why am I crazy?
What did I do?
They deserved it.
They tried to creep our game.
They tried to land where we were landing.
That's all I needed.
Oh, yeah.
And they had a crypto and they had a sniper to contest us.
Yeah, exactly.
that's on them they should have left they fought back so I
have to kill them they got a laser all right I need shield
cells I will play I will play um carbine okay I'm gonna do
triple take that was a good triple take game oh there is I
shouldn't uh fuck yeah i'm gonna actually go oh there's this
new one oh never mind i'm staying on triple take then yeah i
can open the vault oh they're they're resting at the back
here by the way oh okay yeah we can fight them after yeah
yeah i'll go open it we're heading over so broke oh wait
wait wait what hey what is this it's a bug what happened
okay i'm fine oh what happened it's not like um I'm gonna...
I know...
I'm gonna...
No, no, wait.
Okay, okay.
What the fuck?
I know, it's...
It's not...
Okay.
It's an inventory bug.
Like, um...
Yeah, it's inventory bug.
Let's see.
There's triple charger.
Oh, mine.
Yoink.
I just took everything.
Wait, they have crypto?
They have crypto?
Yeah.
What do you know?
Yeah, they do.
They do.
What do you know?
I heard their drone.
My screen.
Here.
There's triple treasure.
I don't need it.
Oh, there's a scope.
I need it.
I took it.
I don't have...
My scope now.
I took it.
Alright.
They have to be over there.
They're right outside here.
Yeah.
Do you have...
Face cams and...
Do you have any energy?
Yeah, I did here.
I also have an extra med kit.
Okay, thank you.
They have Loba.
I'm looking.
They open the door.
Loba crypto.
No, they're far, they're far.
Oh, okay.
Okay, Ken, okay.
I will go.
I'm waiting for you, Ditto.
They're far though, they're far.
Yeah.
Come here, come here.
I will see.
Oh, they're so far.
They're like right here.
Where are us?
Holy shit, do you see this?
One, two, three, four.
Do you see that?
What?
What the fuck are they doing?
Look at the map.
Right here.
Oh my god.
A lot.
Yeah, and then there's here.
One team, it does.
Oh, I got scared, I got scared.
It's fable.
Oh, there, there, there, there, there, there, there.
There's one.
There's one that flew too far.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're getting high ground.
They're flying.
Okay.
I will try to get the anger.
I think they're running.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah, I think they went to the ring.
They're gone, gone, gone.
I think we should go lower siphon.
Yeah, yeah.
Take this.
This has armor for you, Hiro.
Okay.
I will carve battle you first.
Yeah.
Evil cash.
Okay.
I'm just getting a...
Okay, okay.
Alright, let's get the lava siphon!
We should!
Yeah, we should get the lava siphon now.
Yes.
Let me see, we should go here.
Hmm.
Third floor?
Third floor is the base, I think.
I'll wait.
Wait, wait, wait for my zip line?
Alright.
We're here.
Okay.
Here, here.
Oh no, we can't.
Wait.
Tito, what are you doing?
You're IGN!
Come here, come here, come here!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Yay!
There might be people here.
God, this zip line is lagging.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait, the zip line is fine for me.
I think it's you.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, bye-bye, my spies, spies!
Okay.
A hundred and two.
We go check that building.
Okay, okay, okay.
There's no one, I think.
Okay, okay.
I'll just go take it.
I'm gonna poke a little bit.
They're not looking.
They're scared.
Wait, I still have no shields.
Oh, then let's get this.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
You're gonna, you're gonna, you're gonna get it.
Okay, third, third point is the base, I think.
Okay, I need a shield cell.
I just realized I have zero shield cells.
I didn't give you some.
Why?
Because I forgot to loot.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I don't need bats.
I have a lot of bats so you can take the bat.
Really?
Yeah, I have seven bats.
Oh, there, there, there, there.
Oh yeah.
One team there.
Sell the bottom ducky.
Grab it.
He's one tech.
He's...
There's people behind us.
What the heck?
Why you shoot me?
There's a team in that small house.
There's a team in small house.
Okay.
Let me look.
We have three.
We have our teammate?
Uh, no.
Not yet.
70%.
Wait, they're coming over.
They're coming over.
Like...
What?
all cracked yeah but we can't do anything about it they're
all one guy there two guys two guys above us i'm gonna okay
i will need i will need i will need i need it too no i hit
the railing hey above us yeah yeah we gotta make sure nobody
i'm gonna make sure nobody's behind uh below us i'm on the
other door there's people here too here
oh my god yeah i'm looking below us too okay because they
want to they want to i want people to flank us here no i
didn't i haven't i think um hero hero pay here pay here pay
at the um did you drop they opened the door wait i have uh i
have a wait wait no no no no 200 okay okay oh they went back
they went over i can't get Yeah, I'm gonna close.
He's scared.
That's why.
Closing the store.
Wait, did it close?
The wind's back?
I'm gonna close the store for us.
They're scared.
They went back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They can't go through the store now.
They're off.
Careful.
Okay.
Another squad.
I guess can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, can.
I'm not gonna use, I'm gonna go peek anymore.
I don't have many cells.
Yeah, there's a, there's a, uh...
Here.
I'll just take everything.
okay i'm gonna make sure okay oh my god they're crazy wait
they're coming on top of us really yeah that's fine the guy
they're they're above us okay that's fine i'm gonna i'm
gonna scan them okay okay we we play this alone okay okay
okay i'm trying to see How many people above us?
Two?
Okay.
Yeah.
Only two.
Let me check the rest.
This one, the beauty is more sale.
This one, this one, there's one person down here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm looking around behind us here.
I'm looking here.
There's a team here.
How many battalions do you guys have?
I have seven.
I have eight, actually.
We can have so many.
Can I have, can I have some?
Here, here's two.
Go ahead.
There's one team here.
That's another top quest.
Someone look below us just in case.
Okay.
I'll take a bat later.
I'll just go look around now.
I'm checking.
They're fighting.
There's so many people.
Oh my god, so many people died.
We're still here.
We're still inside the zone.
There's so many people died though.
Holy shit.
This is zone.
This is zone right here.
Or that.
Wait, wait, hello.
Am I still here?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
My internet.
Oh no!
You're still in, you're still in.
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm here.
You're just flying around, you're flying.
Yeah, I see a drone flying around, you're still here.
Let me check.
You're still in here.
You know, how many like ammo do you have?
I have...
I can give you here.
I can give a bit.
Thank you.
Okay, I'll give you 20.
That's it.
I can give you some.
I can give.
Here.
Here, diddle.
Thank you.
Holy shit, there's a team here too.
I get EMP.
Just tell me who do EMP.
I feel like we have to MP the people above us.
Because they're the most annoying.
Me too.
Do you want to go down?
Do you want to go down to rotate or above?
Let me check.
Let me check above us.
guy it's one guy it's a one guy okay one guy do you want to
fight him do you just kill it i can't not moving yeah yeah
well i can do now i'm gonna just kill him oh he just moved
are you fucking kidding me here are they calling chores he
literally just moved the moment you said it's one but did it
get bad like like like his team is gone did it get bad i
don't know what happened to them Oh my god man.
That is so funny!
What happened?
No, he just disappeared.
I'm getting ready to EMP this.
Where?
Here.
89.
All broken?
I can't do anything about it.
Okay, I have no anger.
I have no anger.
Yeah, I will go outside the building.
I'm going here.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab some nades too.
But there's a guy there.
There's a guy there too.
There too.
I'll go there.
Almost kicked on that guy.
Oh my god, he ran so fast.
If you guys find sniper ammo, let me know.
This team, this team, this team.
I really need sniper ammo.
I got scanning from my left.
That's them.
Almost kicked on the live line?
I don't have an angle.
I'm charging my alt.
Okay.
There's a team here.
There's a team there.
Really behind this.
Yeah, team here too.
Team here.
That one's cracked, Ditto.
Okay, I have no anger.
I'm trying.
I'm getting bats.
Do you guys need bats here?
I have so many bats.
They're resting there.
Can... Can...
Can we go...
Okay.
Wait, they scan us again, Ditto.
I'm going to Ditto.
I'm going to go.
We are going to go to Ditto.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, Ditto.
We're trying to get to you.
Oh, I'm getting shot.
Yeah.
do this i'm going inside i'm going inside the bin oh no i'm
dead okay down i don't want i'm in the barrel i'm in the
barrel oh my god i can't oh sorry you can you can you can
rest me he's right there is a no oh no oh my gosh no that's
you no we should have stayed we should have stayed yeah
thank you That team That team Are you Are you flat?
You check Click on the rank And see if you're flat Click on
rank Let me shake Let me shake Not yet Yeah How much Really?
How much more?
150 It's okay 150 Yeah It's okay Oh my god We need one win
We need one win Okay, we'll win this one.
All right, we can do it.
I should have kept my triple take.
I was so happy getting the longbow.
I should have played with my triple take.
You get another one this round.
It's always, always a triple take and the longbow.
I see gold longbow.
I don't I don't play longbow actually Oh longbow is fun I
mean when you have the gold site It's just the gold site the
gold site Oh the gold site When you get the gold site it's
like Oh I want it You can see everything Yeah it's just so
fun to see everything No
We need Yeah, we need Ditto to get a lot of kills.
The moment she hits 150, we know it's over.
Oh, that was Siphon.
Yeah.
Oh, Chalabine.
Chalabine is not that...
There's...
Wait, there's not a song.
Ooh.
It's only...
What?
It's just long range.
Wait, they're landing together.
What?
Ooh.
Yeah, the two teams, all of them.
Oh, all of them.
Three teams?
Okay, I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
They all landed together.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Ooh.
One guy.
Why?
They, but they didn't fight.
What is that?
They're not fighting.
Oh, they're not fighting.
Okay, now.
It was slow.
Okay.
You want to go?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Yeah, yeah.
Lady.
Okay, let's go together.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm heading over here.
Wait, there's one guy on top.
Ditto.
Oh, wait, wait.
Yeah, I heard that here.
Yeah, how did I get burned?
I was like running here.
You're so far from it.
I tried one.
Three other squads around.
But they didn't fly.
What?
Oh, my God.
Be careful.
Okay, we'll wait a little bit.
We wait.
I'll wait a bit.
What do you tell Knox?
Yeah, let me look.
Let me look.
Okay.
They're here.
They're down.
Some people are down here.
I saw a knock.
You can come.
Cracked him.
I'm gonna shield cell.
This is this guy.
I can stay.
One hit.
Oh, careful.
I'm going with here on the team on the team last team.
Oh, but Flash flash flash flash flash.
Oh, God.
Oh, God Flash to nice crazy.
Okay, he's easy.
Okay, you can you can you can touch me.
Yeah, I was trying to I'm trying.
I'm gonna get the armor swap right now Okay, get the light
armor.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh That one there.
Yeah.
Whoa Oh God.
Oh my God.
I gotta get cut here oh goodbye goodbye oh nice i'm out nice
nice nice did we do you kill all them yeah yeah okay okay
okay why did you cute my body it's a sacrifice i had to make
all right let me grab i grab a car all right wait there's
You said there were three squads.
Wait, let me check.
Let me check.
I remembered.
It was like three squads.
Wait, there's no...
They're all dead.
No squads?
Okay, okay.
That's good.
That's what we needed.
Yeah, yeah.
Now the loot is all ours.
Nice.
We have all the loot now.
Wow.
We are so good.
Yeah.
Oh my god, they looted this too.
Oh.
Do you need beds, guys?
I have two.
I'll give you some.
Wait, are you here, Doki?
Where are you?
Okay, I'm all the way here.
Do you need this?
I need some light, I think.
Light?
Okay, light.
I can give you.
I can craft.
Okay.
I have like 200.
Oh, yeah, you should.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you don't need a craft.
That was 300.
Wait, here.
Okay, $1.20.
Yeah, I need that.
100 120 all right where do we go much light that's a lot
holy shit what the fuck i have 300 are you in you're not
even running double light you're not you just have 300 no oh
okay do you want more bats there's not more bats here no i'm
okay oh wait i'm gonna scan the ring yeah but i look at
rabbit yeah i don't i don't have a can you Call for me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's nobody here.
You know, I'll...
Early?
Yeah.
Wait, there's one squad.
Oh, no!
She's out.
It's the fake news.
Let me check.
Okay.
I don't see them here.
Yeah, how is I supposed to know?
They're here.
They just came.
They're gonna loot.
We can fight.
Okay.
I can't.
They're white.
Okay, okay, so they're babies.
They're babies.
Okay, only one.
They're looting here.
Yeah, yeah, they won loot.
They won loot because they're babies.
I hear them.
Uh, gas.
There's gas.
On me.
You mean caustic?
Yeah, yeah, caustic, caustic, caustic.
Wait, behind me?
Oh, my God.
There was a guy right behind me.
Over here, over here.
Whoa, goodbye.
It's not low.
I'm coming in, did it.
He's not low.
Don't worry, I'm coming back soon.
I'm almost there.
Nice last guy.
Hey guys, I'm back.
Wait, wait, wait.
You come back?
Oh my god.
You guys, I'm saved.
There's so many things here.
Wait, here, gold knock.
What the fuck?
Why were they, how are they like, and rich i thought they
were solo oh my god the guy was behind me they had nothing
they had like white armor but they had items yeah they were
fucking goaded what the heck there's so much stuff i mean i
need energy armor okay here energy there's a lot of energy
here too yeah okay okay okay okay i got it oh hell okay i
lived let's see i died right next to the cart that was fun
You can scan Ring now.
Okay.
Yeah, you can scan it now.
No scar.
Okay.
I will.
All right, while you scan, I'll get the Evo.
Okay.
Turkey, give me some Dawn.
No.
Dawn.
You're just...
You're just one HP.
Come over here.
And then you get it.
You have to come over here.
Ooh, wait, that's a PK.
I don't like the PK.
Put the dawn there.
Let's see.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
You like PK?
Oh, the ring.
No, no, I mean the ring.
The ring is um, it's hard to pin it.
That's true.
Oh, yeah.
I should wait, wish I don't like landslides.
No, I'll get I'll give you I'll give you the the tower, you
know.
Okay.
Yeah, you give me this.
Is no one with the PK?
No.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
Really?
Yeah, I'm gonna do it with like two or three.
200 ping or Let's go Oh, you have 200 ping No, I have 100
100 ping 120 I think That's usually how much ping I get Do
you need energy?
Okay, I'm good I'm good Um, we go Countdown Countdown?
Alright, alright Let's look Ballet here Oh my god, let me
place my thing Alright, who wants the red armor you can grab
it oh i can okay i need it yeah yeah i need it the most if
i'm going with my pk oh there's another gold rose okay yeah
yeah yeah i'll go get it yeah oh i don't like to this way
and this way oh we should go this way we get to landslide
okay let's see if if there's no one in landslide but i i
think i think there might be people at and we can go here
and let's see if uh hero scans anybody oh yeah yeah yeah if
you scan somebody now let me gosh do he what you are so
smart i know i know i know you're so smart let's see i'll
grab this sounds like okay um that's scan song all right we
gotta wait for hero to see how many teams are around i will
go grab um evil harvester yeah and nobody near nobody near
then we could go through this yeah we should be able to go
through this yeah where do you want to go there's one team
there you want to fight or do you want to oh oh oh ditto
wants to fight now can you scan there where okay it's oh
yeah here okay it's I yeah, yeah, yeah It's a team, there's
a team here too, yeah Dido you want to go?
There's a team there too Um We could just wait until it
closes Yeah, okay It's blue armor by the way, I cracked him
I cracked him from all the way here Let me see, let me try
and then Okay Yeah, I'm gonna look behind us here too, just
in case Okay, team, team, team, team We have to look around
this Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Make them back up No, no, three,
three, three.
I saw three.
One fell.
Yeah, one ran down.
I'll EMT.
Hello, hello, hello.
Yeah, I know.
Blue, blue, purple.
Blue, purple.
Let me check.
They're all the way down here.
They're here.
Why are they running to us?
We cracked them.
Here.
Two.
Two people there.
Yeah, the third... Their third ran in the different
direction.
Low armor?
They're trying to run.
Be careful.
Flash, flash, flash!
That's a different squad?
What?
No, no, no, it's his teammate.
I got one!
Oh, right there!
Nice!
Last, there's a rev over there.
I got two.
You're the key?
Yeah, all dead, all dead.
We got kill, we got kill, we got kill.
I don't know if they're all dead though.
I think one flew.
Over there, over there.
We go, we go, right?
We go, right?
Yeah.
Don't kick you!
Oh, sorry.
Oh, they get keeping us.
Yeah, yeah, so we have to go this way.
They get keeping us.
We can't...
Okay.
Let me check.
Let me drone.
I'll drone.
I can scan.
This is zone.
This zone.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll throw my drone down here.
Woo.
Oh, that's a lie.
No way.
I saw them over here earlier.
I'm not sure where they are now.
Wait, I don't see them actually.
Yeah, then we need to move up.
Wait, they're not here.
They're not here.
Get out of the tunnel.
Can we play on the...
Nobody here.
Nobody's here.
Everybody's fighting there.
Okay, we're all there.
Yeah, yeah, get the ring.
Get the ring too.
We take the high guard, we take the high guard.
Yeah, you scan the ring because all them are fighting here.
They don't scan ring.
Okay, I will scan the ring.
I'm gonna check the package.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
one two three teams oh it's here okay we should we should
push up here now okay okay okay i'll push up here we care
package though yeah it's a divo does anyone want to get
someone no there's another one coming down here oh someone
should get the divo i'll take it i'll take it you can you
can take it i'll grab i'll stay here but there's there's
another one here though i will look left i will look like
what that is first i'm gonna look right here uh because let
me check for you And then another team is here at left side.
Over there, over there, over there, over there.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna put my package here too.
I should know we're here as well.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
There was only two team left.
Yeah.
So, live and die.
But there's another devotion.
Oh shit, okay, I'll grab one of the devotion.
I'll grab the other one.
Yeah, okay.
You take one.
Okay.
I'll grab that.
I have a lot of energy.
Do you guys need?
Uh, no.
I'm running two...
I'm running PKD.
Where's Dan?
Wait, they're okay.
They're there.
They're fighting?
Oh, wait.
Push up, push up, push up.
They're fighting.
You gotta push up.
Uh, Hito, you gotta come up.
Yeah, I'm a bit far.
Wait.
Yeah, just run up.
They're heavy fighting.
Heavy fighting.
Hard fight.
I'll try and EMP them.
Let me EMP.
Okay.
I act on the town.
One left side, EMP left side.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm going on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They didn't, they got, they got one knock.
IMP the other one.
Did, did, did, did this, we can actually fight here.
Oh, they're all dead.
Oh, come.
Oh.
They're not, they're not dead.
No, no, no.
We have to focus on the left side too.
This one is very hurt, very hurt.
Yeah.
I can't, I don't have an angle on this team.
I'm looking at my right just in case.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
oh my god I forgot Devo's recoil is so hard I'm gonna look
at this team for us
this team right here I'm looking here for us this team is
blue armor yeah they're all this team is blue as well
oh on the left team left team have um left team have three
people we have to focus on left team yeah you guys focus on
left i'm focusing on right for us okay okay wait one's
pushing up did it oh this one that's fine that's fine yeah
okay all right guys calm down they're here they're here hey
you used to do it kill yeah yeah yeah my drone just broke
they're trying to get they they're The one, though.
Left team, no.
They keep destroying my drone, but it keeps getting...
All right.
I'm getting across.
I'm getting across on the left, the right team.
Okay.
They might push up to us.
So I'm going to be sure.
Right on the left team.
They're there, Doki.
They're there.
Yeah.
They're right here.
They're right here on me.
Right here.
They're lacing.
All right.
They're on you, Dito.
The left team, they're lacing.
They're pushing me.
They're pushing you?
Yeah.
You need help.
Are you guys okay?
Wait, one hit.
One hit.
Catalyst.
Come over.
Give me a sec.
I'm fine.
I'm not pushing.
Let's pull back.
Actually, let's get zone.
We're not even in zone.
No, I'm going out.
I'm going out.
Go up, go up.
Yeah, I'll be bottom.
I'll be bottom.
Okay.
Right here?
I didn't even want to push up.
Are you fighting each other?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pushing up.
Costner is cracked.
I'll crack.
Okay.
Costner is cracked too.
I knocked one.
I got one.
Okay.
I'm going to Doki.
on me on me oh my god this is dumb one hit one hit in the in
the in the cart in the cart okay be careful be careful be
careful yeah okay last guy they're inside nice one last one
no solo solo oh my god oh i can't oh my god got him I'm just
like fuck off get out of there yeah he's just sitting inside
he's just like he's staying in there oh my god we did it
that has to be plat that has to be a champion that's a
champion nice oh Nice.
We are champion.
Let's see.
I'm returning the lobby.
Yeah, I'm returning the lobby too.
It definitely is, right?
Surely.
I got gold one from that.
I got 330 points from that.
I'm gold.
Oh, yeah, gold.
We got plus.
We did it.
We accomplished our goal.
Both the goals.
Yeah.
We reached 600.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah.
Because when you rank up to another tier, yeah i got i got
764 guys i got 330 guys i got okay you almost you almost get
um planned almost planned guys yeah gg that was fun we are
so we are so good yeah we're so good our teamwork is so good
i know we're fucking gamers like oh my god we're so good
guys like look at look at us we climbed so much we got like
wins against other master players we're so good ggs i had a
lot of fun yeah guys oh my god we played yeah we played for
five hours oh my god we played so long we were so long so
hungry oh my gosh i don't have fun though i had so much fun
that was we should do this again we should definitely grind
again yeah yeah all right ggs guys okay yeah Feels good to
see you guys Alright bye bye I'm going to talk to my dragons
Bye bye Bye Bye Bye Bye I'm going to go on my ride Yeah go
eat Go eat I'll eat See you Bye bye Bye Oh That was so fun I
had a great time Playing with Kiro and Ditto We cried at We
like won so many games Oh my god We won so many games
together And like Our teamwork was so good good um i'm gonna
go back to y'all land oh i had an incredible time today uh
tomorrow is uh one uh once human launch with uh tangent
tomorrow um i was not expecting to stream for five hours but
it was really fun though like we won so many games we frag
the fuck out today my aim uh when i got warmed up my aim was
like killing it until like i forgot how to control the
devotion recoil but other than that
other than that um i had a great time um wait let's see wait
i need to double check is the youtube's figure still feel
orderable guys in 10 hours guys okay before i leave i need a
shill
guys all i'm saying is like you need this for for the figure
triforce look your your your shrine is gonna look real silly
if it's incomplete you need if we're completing the triforce
we need like the u-tus the nendroid and the funco pop i will
not stop until i get a funco pop but it's gonna look really
silly if you don't have the U2's figure to start it up
but yes the YouTube figures has 10 hours left before it's
gone forever so feel free to pre-order it before it's gone
gone gone gone gone
is the Funko Pop confirmed no but I will not stop until I
get that Funko Pop so I can complete the try for us guys
it's like okay you know like um what was it what's that word
called when people have like an oscar a baffa a tony oh my
gosh what is it called um when you have an oscar baffa tony
uh egot yes this is our egot so you know how celebrities who
get win like the egot which is basically like an emmy Grammy
Oscar and Tony Award.
This is going to be my Egot.
So, like, I'm going to get, like, it's called the Triforce,
because it means you get a figure for, like, for, like,
every well-known figure place.
So, like, Funko Pop, U-2s, and Nendroid.
So, we have, like, so we've got to make sure, like, yeah,
the Funko Pop will appear once you purchase the other two.
Yeah, the Holy Trinity.
So, guys, we have to complete the collection.
Anyway, guys, that's so fun.
I had a great time with Hiro and Ditto.
We were really, really good together, all of us.
We were fracking the fuck out.
And I had an incredible time with them.
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm really tired.
We stream five hours of Apex.
So I'm gonna call it here.
My throat needs to rest now.
But thank you all for the gifted membership.
Me, thank you for the 20 gift gifts, ships, thank you, thank
you for all the Akas thank you all for the gifted ships
thank you all for the memberships um Minecraft update I'm
sorry if you guys haven't got whitelisted yet uh regarding
the Minecraft server we're very slowly like getting through
the whitelist because like we're uh implementing a new chat
system uh for the for it and uh within a few days so within
a few days we're gonna have a new the chat system where you
can chat within your factions you can chat within the group
and you can chat global chat so there's like three different
like I'm pretty I'm not sure yet how many chats there's
gonna be in the future we're going to have a server made
regarding the Minecraft server and we're planning on hiring
a full-on moderation team that handles just the server
because it got a lot bigger than I expected it to be a lot
of people are joining the Minecraft server and it's getting
a lot bigger than I expected it so we're going to have
regular updates and we're going to have donations to the
server so that it goes straight to the Minecraft development
team so like Because we were talking about it.
Because, you know, I use your super chats, your memberships
to fund the Minecraft server.
But I figured it would be.
Why are you so?
Why my talk?
What do you mean, Ditto?
I am so nice.
I was so nice.
I'm not toxic, Ditto.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I was not toxic at all.
Anyway, anyway.
So, like, we're talking about, like, funding it.
Because I put down payment for...
for like a couple uh we're already using we're almost used
up all the payment regarding like server updates so we're
talking about like future funding and like i already used
your guys like when your money goes towards like uh future
investments in the channel so i pitched an idea that like uh
for those who want to fund the minecraft server we're gonna
have a specific donation link that just goes straight to the
minecraft server because i was like because we're like oh
we're at first they're like whoa there's two minute steps to
it because they're gonna donate to you so you and you just
pay us and then i was like yeah but they really want to
donate to the minecraft server and they donate to me youtube
takes 30 of that so i might as well like if they want to go
directly to the server itself and it goes towards the team
um and it goes towards the team towards the minecraft server
specifically um i told them to make a uh fund just for that
and when we reach that fund uh and when you reach that fund
uh you guys won't need to donate anymore And then it goes
straight into development.
Like, so they just grab the money from that fund.
The Minecraft team will just grab the money from that fund.
And just use that to improve more and more on the server.
And, like, more and more updates and everything.
So, because I was already funding the server.
But I thought, like, since, like, you guys are sending
donations and super chats to me.
And I put it towards the server.
It just makes it more easier to just, like, have it directly
to them.
YouTube taking 30% of the cut.
But I already put in my own money regarding future
improvements to the server.
But after that, we're planning on having a donation goal.
Not donation goal, but just if you want to provide more, if
you want to fund for future updates on the server.
And when we hit that certain goal, we cap it so that people
don't over-donate, you know.
And then the team just grabs the funds to create more stuff.
and um and that's what we're doing for the server uh so yeah
i didn't realize how how like like how much work i guess how
much it was gonna grow into because like i didn't realize
there's so many people that was like so like it was like it
was getting more bigger it's actually turning into a real s
&p so like i i was not expecting that like i was not
expecting it to like actually turn into like a real ass SMP
thing so
so we're it's like getting growing more it's like it's
growing more and more every day um um but yes I really
apologize uh if you're not whitelisted yet we're handling it
slowly because there's like a lot of other stuff we're
dealing with at the moment so um and we're gonna try and
we're going we're planning on streamlining the white white
list a little bit more in the future uh regarding the server
stuff uh discord server also love thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you my husband enjoys your minecraft
game even take no i'm sorry that means you gotta join
minecraft too you have to play minecraft too so you can go
on minecraft dates on my server all right i'm gonna head off
now everybody as always everyone stay hydrated posture check
get up and move around to get that for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye